Donald Trump has secured a victory in
the Supreme Court simply by the Supreme
Court saying no to special counsel Jack
Smith Trump's trying to argue that he's
got immunity this would delay the trial
for Donald Trump at the federal level
until after the election so Jack Smith
is desperately trying to force through
this criminal Tri bypassing the appeals
process but it didn't work Supreme Court
said hold your horses there buddy ain't
going to happen which means massive
victory for Trump at least in one of his
cases it's not going to go to trial
until after the election already happens
and this is federal so it should be
really interesting to see what happens
because Trump will probably just pardon
himself should be very interesting and
then we've got some big breaking news
the Border crisis is getting crazy more
and more people are coming out with huge
stories pertaining to the documentation
that these illegal immigrants are being
given the finances the resources we're
hearing they're being flown on planes
and we've got James O'Keefe here to join
us with some big breaking news before we
get started my friends head over to C
brew.com buy some coffee it's the end of
the year we got a cast Brew gift card
now available it's a featured product we
just we've got appalachin kns our dark
roast everyone's favorite to be honest
uh rise with Berto junor if you want to
support the show you buy coffee from Cas
brew.com and uh it helps us produce uh
uh more products and it also helps fun
the show we also uh I want to shout out
the link in the description below go to
you YouTube music. you.com subscribe to
our music channel the first week of our
release for the new song together again
is over we ended the week with 8.7
million plays suck on that far-left
crybabies they're all screaming and
everybody's like Tim oh your music sucks
I'm like bro I'm chilling you don't have
to like my music I'm not saying
everybody does okay but this one is I
think it's fair to say the daily wire
really helped out with this is why it's
probably done better than the other
songs Michael nolles Jeremy boring this
is originally written by them we made a
modern version of it uh sales are
looking good this looks to be the
biggest release we've done so far
however the difference with the other
songs we released those in the Rock
genre probably easier to chart on
Billboard than that so we'll see what
happens this is Pop I'm not I don't know
how well we'll end up doing but uh thank
you to everybody look we've got like
five or six songs we released we're
hoping next year we're going to have a
lot more everyone saying you need more
bands totally get it we right now have
like just Carter Banks one guy who's
working on all this music and so we
certainly a lot more to do but it means
we're going to be expanding as we're
moving into the new space we're going to
have a bigger opportunity and we're
talking with a few artists we're talking
with some major major bands about uh
working with us and we're working out
what that deal would look like because
we're not doing things traditionally but
a lot of big cultural moves are
happening head over to
timcast.net
so uh it's a pay what you will model if
you like it then you join us you become
a member you join the Discord server you
hang out with like-minded individuals
and Monday through Thursday you get
uncensored members only content and I
got to tell you uh we may be about to
sign a great artist to trash House
Records I'm I'm very excited for this
announcement which uh is a little
preliminary but ladies and gentlemen the
great artist James O'Keefe maybe maybe
joining the ranks not maybe definitely
we uh uh so actually James came in early
so we discuss music production because I
mean a lot of people have seen the work
you've already done already in with
music and theater and all that but we're
going to ramp it up I can't wait I I've
got so many good ideas you know I was
the lead in Oklahoma I'm a DJ I I just
haven't had a lot of time but Tim I look
forward to comeing back and uh making
some music absolutely and we're going to
do some uh great videos music videos and
all that stuff but uh James you're here
uh you've got some big breaking news I
believe for us tonight yeah as I was
sitting here right before your show uh
Tim um lot to cover tonight uh and thank
you for having me again this is um a
story after amfest we went to the
airport and uh various flight attendants
Pilots uh ticket counter people pulled
me aside recognized me said you you got
to do something James they're in they're
inundating buses are dropping people off
so I ran up to the bus I got a little
video we'll talk about that in a minute
of the driver of this black car black
car limousine dropping off migrants and
then I obtained today this I just broke
this a moment ago on my ex page if you
want to pull it up these are new these
are tickets they're giving out to
migrants you can look at it it says
quote please help me print my boarding
pass I am a refugee and I do not speak
the language thank you these were given
to me from inside the airlines industry
by some of the folks working there and
they're just flying people around the
government claims it's vetting these
individuals before putting them on
planes but our reporting contradicts
that what we found is the agents
responsible for vetting the ident
ification of these individuals are
relying solely on their word now you and
I couldn't travel without an ID yeah uh
and we have to take off our shoes so
what's what's remarkable about this is
that Tim I I I I've said this to you in
in uh in Phoenix I've been doing this
for 20 years I have never seen so many
pissed off people inside the airlines
mostly Pilots by the way they are pissed
so I I'm really interested in getting
into the the the driver of these cars
like what's going on with this and and
now this breaking story so we'll
definitely get into that James thanks
for hanging out we got Hannah clir
hanging out as well hey I'm Hannah Clair
I'm a writer for cnr.com also known
as scanner news I'm so happy to be here
talking about immigration one of my
favorite topics uh Ian's here too James
you absolute animal welcome to the house
great to be here thanks for ringing out
2023 with us man I love you dude it is
so much better when you're here I'm
looking forward to making Killer music
with you I love your energy man I love
it let's get fried in the best way maybe
that's not the right word let's get hot
let's make some I mean I swear to god
dude we're going to change the world
with sound it's yelling and crapping and
and and complaining it gets you a little
it gets you part way but you want to
solve the system I mean we we're going
to do it it's like you know you're going
to save the world with rock music I
guess is that the plan I guess it is all
right we got Ser the kids oh yeah I love
seeing you all hyped about stuff it's
great got a guitar in my hand thanks
yeah yeah definitely anyways let's get
to the show guys before we jump to the
crazy immigration stuff which I think
will dominate most of the conversation
we do have the story which is uh
important for coming into the next year
cnr.com scotus denies Jack Smith's
request to fast track judgment on
Trump's immunity claims the order
jeopardizes a special council's proposed
March 4th start date this is basically
it Donald Trump's victory in a single
very short sentence the petition for a
RIT of Seri arari before judgment is
denied there you go what this means is
Donald Trump is appealing he's arguing
that he is immune as president and I
believe the the arguments presented
excuse me by legal Scholars sound that a
president does a lot of things
if you think the president has committed
High crimes and misdemeanors treason
sedition whatever it might be you
impeach them convict them and then
criminally charge them the reason why we
don't criminally charge sitting
presidents is that they are the chief
enforcer of law as the head of the
executive branch that means that we
first have to remove them from the
position of law enforcement before we
criminally charge them I think it makes
total sense right now what we're seeing
is it looks like this case the federal
level is not going to happen until after
the election because of this and what
that likely means is Trump will pardon
himself that would be the best move of
all time would so funny realistically I
feel like we're going to jump through
some more legal hurdles before we get
there but uh it would make the Democrats
crazy if we got to the point where Trump
pardoned himself was he going to be like
pardon me and then it'll be like well
all right he said it that actually does
seem like something Donald Trump would
do he'd be he he'd stand up and he'd
smark and he go pardon me can you can
you do that can the president pardon
he just put it on Truth social I am
pardoned and that's it wow he would just
say pardon me that's a good one I'm not
asking I'm telling I'm pardon he signs
it uh I think 2024 is going to be just
balls of the wall crazy W I think all
bets are off it's impossible to predict
we were fasting your seat belts we were
talking with uh Eric Prince earlier this
morning founder of
Blackwater and you know that's one of
the questions I had you know with his
experience in Conflict crisis in you
know foreign war stuff for all the
criticisms I think his Insight still
matters what would it be like like is is
the potential there do you see the signs
and he was just saying
that he basically said gradually then
suddenly that with a lot of the
countries they've seen in crisis even
during krina United States it is
overnight your utilities are gone this
one of the scariest things I think
people don't realize and what he said
was when his guys got to uh uh to uh um
New Orleans from during
Katrina when when they arrived they were
dead bodies all over the place killed by
looters and I said I don't know if
looter is the right word Bandit maybe
Barbarian you know when when people
people take all of our we talked about
high trust Society they take it for
granted when the president of the United
States his authority his position is
questioned and challenged that is
someone taking a hammering a chisel and
striking it into the stone foundation of
this country in this way particularly
and if confidence in the system
shatters gradually as we're seeing and
then suddenly overnight electricity's
off food's not at your store anymore
internet's not working you don't know
what's going on in a circumstance like
that the last place I'd want to be is
like New York Chicago or La I wouldn't
mind just being on the mountain in West
Virginia with some chickens and from
what I've been told if that kind of
thing were to happen and you was a
utility andoun situation you got about
three weeks that you're going to need to
survive on your own and then things will
probably come back but in those three
weeks if you're not prepared not if it's
a civil war not if it turns into
something like that but if it's like a
grid down situation and it's like you've
got a lot of death in the first two
weeks people that aren't prepared at all
and but if you're one of those prepared
people and you're able to like hold out
you should be okay have you guys heard
of a book called 1 second after have you
ever read read this book it's about an
electromagnetic pulse and what happens
to civilization El breaks down within a
few hours when there's no electricity
just what happens and it basically
devolves into of the flies into just
Anarchy and after a few days people
start breaking out into tribes it's it's
crazy you got to read that book I think
you see early signs of that right now
though right we we see communities at
odds with each other every day I mean I
just saw the story today where Charlie
Sheen the actor his neighbor like broke
into his house and tried to strangle him
like people are at odds with one another
every single day there might be other
circumstances there but I think it's
fair to say that trust has degraded
enough to affect Quality of Life as we
know it right now just think about how
crazy it was like in the 18 1800s where
you're some dude who has a farm and you
could be in a feud with a guy like 50
mil away and then he just go over there
kill him and then go back and then
nobody would know I mean this was uh you
never do anything about it what's the
prequel to is it 1889 the like
Yellowstone prequel they have this whole
thing where it's like well we want that
land for our sheep to graze on okay well
we'll come and murder you like they have
shootouts all the time it it it's not as
far back as we think it is right in that
one it's like they were close enough to
the city to where there were questions
about the feud and everything but back
in the day some guy would jump out of
the forest stab you take your stuff and
there ain't no way anyone's going to
figure out it happened I was going to
Tweet out I didn't do it cuz kind of
ridiculous how many people do you think
have
died I'm just talking about of all of
all time yeah oh there's a number you
can Google it really yeah but like you
said you can't track it cuz some people
just they disappear that's not true we
have uh 109 billion people have lived
and died over the course of 192,000
years uh it's it's an estimate obviously
but it's just simply tracking population
size and growth and we know about
population sizes through historical
record except for
tartaria right that was another 100
billion oh sh never forget area yeah
let's let's talk more um well I think
this is a year of doing your best and
maintaining friendships it's going to be
so important to be tight with who you're
tight with and stay tight you know we're
having this discussion with uh uh
Michael malice because he got that bet
with Roseanne and uh what's the bet
Roseanne said there won't be an election
Michael M said I will bet you ,000 there
will be and she said deal she also bet
there would be military tribunals at the
end of this year that Trump would be
arresting people and he laughed and he
bet and I'm like Roseanne that's that's
not going to happen now the question
about election is what do you mean by no
election I think we all agree she meant
it would like chaos the election
wouldn't happen and uh who was was it
colonel McGregor who no it wasn't who
was it who said that we're not going to
make it to 2024's election you might be
right about that I'm not you want to
look it up it was on a podcast it was on
pbd I think and uh uh I I actually think
there's a strong case for that and we
joke with Michael malice that he doesn't
owe Roseanne any money because just
because Trump's been removed from the
ballot doesn't mean there won't be an
election and uh Michael was arguing that
if it's Nikki Haley versus Joe Biden
it's still an election and I'm like Fair
Point agreed but I'm starting to feel
like if it does I'm saying if it
escalates based on everything we're
seeing by May or June the damn could
snap I mean they're talking about
putting the city the former president I
almost said sitting the former president
in prison and 74 million voters more
more votes than any sitting president
this is not going to this is not going
to it's not going to work I mean people
are just going to go insane January 6
already happened they can make any
argument they want about yeah but the
government will stop there what I'm like
dude what what what Eric Prince was
talking about this
morning you got to understand that uh he
said even police in Louisiana are
looting and we talked about this I said
there was a movie and the uh the crew
the audience the chat pointed out World
War Z
Brad Pitt's character goes into the
store to get medicine for his daughter
he sees a cop run in and he's like oh
crap and the cop just looks at him
starts grabbing stuff and then runs cops
are people so when it when it if it
breaks down to this point it's not just
going to be the military being like we
are going to stop all of this yo they
were cops active duty and there were
active duty military on January 6 in the
capital it's not like everybody in the
Army is just like a bunch of liberals
yeah it's not like everybody that's
wearing a cop uniform is going to be a
cop either yeah exactly um I I got a one
of those bow Fang CB radios those little
$20 you know handheld R shortwave radios
and a little solar panel got some solar
panels I mean if if grid down we need to
maintain communication that's primary
number one I don't know exactly the
rules and restrictions of that because
they'll be like stay off of these
channels you can't go on these channels
and I think the thing is if if we were
to go grid down this is the time that
you would want to know your neighbors
and know who's going to be in the houses
next door to you because there's one
thing to say like yes we should all flee
to the woods but realistically if you
live in suburb if you live in a city
you're not going to be able to get out
fast enough if the gr grid G grid goes
down you have to know the people around
you and that's really the big crime of
American culture today which is that we
are more isolated than ever and we are
low trust so we are unlikely to reach
out to the people next door to us and
therefore we're surrounding ourselves
with strangers why do you think people
feel low trust I mean this is something
they've documented over time right like
the we are not a community based people
we are not as involved in community
service we don't attend church as much
and so I think it's just sort of um a
cultural shift some of it I would argue
has to do with values right uh you can
say we all have the same values but
unless you live and breathe the values
we don't really know what they are and I
think also we are more divided Society
politically and so we are taught to
train to look at everyone who doesn't
vote the same way we do as the other and
that's uh an unrealistic way to live
trust is everything trust is confidence
a government only exists based on trust
I'm not saying trust as in if Ian tells
me he'll pay me back I trust he will
that's a component but trust is also I
know that if I break the law I can trust
in government to punish me or someone
else I know that if someone tries to
break into my house I can trust that the
police will be there low trust Society
doesn't just mean we have faith in each
other it means do we have faith in this
system and as we're moving closer and
closer to or as as trust in society is
dropping rapidly it will eventually come
to a point where it's no different than
if there was no government so when you
know Eric Prince is mentioning there
guys show up after being called in by
the government saying we need security
and they find dead bodies that's a zero
trust Society random guys with guns
don't care who you are don't want to
bother with it they're hungry and they
need stuff and you're in the way you die
that could happen gradually as well as
you know hurricane comes floods the city
everyone's in panic and Chaos the system
is broken law enforcement is in is
disheveled and looting and running no so
trust is gone the problem is I think
that some people are they kind of are
waiting for it to happen and are like
ready for the moment the power goes down
to just jump like another George Floyd
riots uh Summer of Love kind of thing
exactly like they're not even going to
wait two days to before they're just
like we are so that I'm very concerned
about that they're already doing it we
are seeing the videos over the past
several years of people just storming
into buildings and raiding them and
taking whatever they want and it's and
you know what it is there's trust in
this they trust the government will do
nothing to stop them they trust no one
will stop them so the government will uh
I should say law enforcement will ARR
you for illegally bearing guns they
describe as illegal I think the
Constitution says otherwise and then
when the criminals come and Rob and
destroy your property they say what are
we supposed to do about it so the system
is designed to fail right now there
we're already at the point of almost no
trust what happens in the summer of this
year when it's looking like Donald Trump
will win or they take action to in some
way stop Donald Trump from winning Eric
Prince pointed out the only other time
the Democrats a president had been
removed from the ballot and it was
Democrats who did it was Abraham Lincoln
a year later the country was in a Civil
War uh VI made an interesting tweet uh I
think it was yesterday he said if you
think that Donald Trump or Joe Biden are
getting anywhere near the White House
what is wrong with you like the way he
phrased it was like there's no way in
hell that's going to happen so Trump or
Biden yeah he's kind of like I think
he's he sees something about the way
that the Deep State works and the way
that the powers of be kind of want the
situation to go and they are the ones
with all the secret police
so he just kind of consigned himself to
it I don't know if the tweet's still up
I'm looking for it it's about about you
sure it's a real tweet uh a fake one
here it is it's from 20 hours ago from
VI on his page if you really if you
really think quote they are going to let
either Trump or Biden get anywhere near
the Finish Line open your eyes folks
there's something deeper going on it's
starting it's staring us right in the
face but who is they though yeah who is
they put inotes thank you yay for giving
us that Meme and it it's could be way
bigger than the American deep state it
could be even bigger than that who knows
but does I mean we have to ask yay who
is they though uh I think one of the
problems with tweets like this is like
and I I think V is an interesting guy
you know I respect what he's doing I
think one of the problems is it's not
solution oriented I wish there was a
little bit more towards like there is
something deeper going on and I think
that's that's our big problem right now
is that people are are ready to panic
but we you have when there's an issue
you have to remain calm and and come up
with a solution what I like about the
tweet and I kind of agree with it's not
a solution oriented tweet is that he's
kind of like hey don't follow that
dangling carrot that's kind of what that
tweet read to me interesting well if
they don't if they don't let the person
who wins the election win there's going
to be there's going to be a kind of
Civil Disobedience SL civil unrest
inside society's institutions not
necessarily the way we think for example
whistleblowing the Civil Disobedience
takes place in many forms and I told
talk to you about this today we we do
you guys remember when there was a a
we've seen all these parents going to
school boards and complaining and then
there was one I can't remember where it
was where all the parents just among
themselves voted to replace the board
and they said that's not the official
procedure so it doesn't count but all
the parents there were like nope we've
all voted we are now the school board
there is going to be an interesting
clash between populism and
credentialism where you will have in a
small town let's say this's a town of
5,000 people and they'll all be like who
here is a is is an agreement that we
should do X and they'll go ah everyone
cheers and you'll have three guys the
official law enforcement Chiefs or
whatever being like no because we're
actually in charge and that's going to
create an interesting conundrum conflict
between what these people end up doing
and how the state level county level or
federal level authorities respond to
these kinds of conflicts I don't think
they can they can handle it if it's if
it's in Moss if it's a numbers game
right agreed there's not enough law
enforcement to handle populist Uprising
right and I don't mean violent Uprising
that's not I'm talking about kind of a a
you're talking about like a Disobedience
inside the corporation or the NGO well
not even not even that I'm saying like
5,000 residents of a small town
somewhere just all come out one day and
say our Sheriff has abandoned us and is
allowing illegal immigrants to run
rampant through our country we are
taking control we we the people and so
it will come to a point where they're
going to go yes but elections are held
based on these procedures and you have
to do it this way and they're going to
say we're all the people who live here
and we all agree we will do it the way
we want right governments only operate
on the consent of the Govern right
except the reality of it right now is
the people are subjects of the federal
government and so the authorities this
is like what we saw with the parents the
parents said we hereby vote you out and
the board were like nope we're the
official board you can't do it and so I
don't even know where that went but it's
going to come to the point where
Grassroots individuals shift their
confidence their trust in in what they
believe but government will not let that
power go have you noticed James that
Disobedience has been On The Rise within
corporations and uh 100% it's in the
last month so I mean the whistleblowing
involves a crisis of conscience they
have to weigh their loyalty to the
organization versus to the public
interest and and and I think that you
know with the story that we're we're
going to talk about here tonight with
these airline pilots actually St Clair
did you see that video this week yeah it
was just like an explosion it's it's
just everything sort of been festering
and getting to this point and it just
blew open like this little Civ of Pilots
I did a spaces with her and I would say
about 70% of airline pilots are more
conservative and about 80 to 90% of the
ticket agents are more liberal so you
know these PE these people inside the
airlines you know they they're they're
they're begging me to do something about
it you know expose these buses are
dropping people off so it's remarkable
it's a remarkable scene I mean I was
cornered in in the airport by these uh
Airline workers it was like the the Sami
stop the Soviet Union don't don't get
Whispering I don't want to be seen with
you but the buses are pulling up in 20
minutes so that that's that's a new
phenomena and and they could lose their
jobs and then one of the one of the
people has a husband and she doesn't
want her husband to know that she's
talking to me you know what I mean these
are these are these are incredible
moments that I've never experienced
before I think it has a lot to do with
uh this growing realization I suppose
it's very
simple when I what I've talked about for
the past several years
if you keep your head down and keep your
mouth shut and keep working for
companies because your argument is I
have a family I have children to feed
you there's a lot of people who are like
Tim you don't have kids you don't
understand how hard it is I can't lose
my job how will my kids eat the attitude
you know my attitude is like you are
absolutely correct that does not change
the fact you are standing with Satan
yeah cuz people not everyone can grow
food you can get a vertical little guard
in your kitchen but like if you've known
for a decade that you could get a
vertical Farm in your kitchen and grow a
little bit of crops for your kids to eat
and you haven't done it yet you might
want to question your sanity well it's
it's this it's this to all the people
out there who say you know I would not
blow the whistle I'm seeing like you
know James is mentioning a lot of people
are stepping forward now more people are
coming forward I think the point is
they're realizing this point and this
point is did you think when and this is
figurative or literal depending on how
you want to take it if you're a person
of Faith or not did you think the devil
when offering you a deal would only
offer you luxury instead of necessity
it's it's an absurd proposition a deal
with the devil isn't how would you like
an infinity pool and a golden statue of
yourself because people don't care about
those things the deal with the Devil is
always how would you like your children
to have full bellies every night serve
me on your knees and I will make sure
your children are fed yeah and so I
understand the terrifying nature of the
the the fan deal but so many people when
I when I heard this from Owen Shroyer
about the prison guards I'm like those
guards saying I know your work I like
what you do I'm just doing my job what
they are telling you is I signed the
devil's contract I think a lot of people
though are it's like Eric Maxis I
talking it's like acid in your heart and
it's like I want I need to keep my job
well you can mic says you can keep your
job and go to
hell and my children and again I don't
have children and I can't fully
empathize but I I would say your
children are going to respect you you're
you're going they're going to respect
you more if you if you do the right
thing maybe not I me I'll be honest like
I'm not I'm not sitting here to pretend
that it's it's easy in any way it's
probably the hardest imaginable thing
again I don't have kids I I respect that
and your kids may not understand see I
think it's the hardest imaginable thing
but you're stronger having gone through
it I think your kids will respect you
when they're older and they fully
understand the sacrifices made I mean
when I look back at the founding fathers
we're talking about wealthy dudes who
had literally no reason to revolt no no
no hold on like there's a lot of
grievances they listed
but these were grievances as leaders and
they were upset about what was being
done to their communities and the future
for their children when I said they had
no reason I'm saying these guys could
have kissed the pinky ring of the king
and been wealthy and wanted for nothing
but they saw that the crown was abusive
they saw that the regulars were abusive
they saw Farmers being killed and they
said we will not sit idly by in our
luxury and comfort we will risk our
sacred honor our treasure our blood our
families and they did and that is
inspiration that is resp man Ben
Franklin lost basic what are you going
to say I was going to say the thing is
they believed that there was a better
option for their children and so this
argument of like well I have kids I need
to provide for them is completely
reasonable I understand that fear on the
other hand if you are helping a company
that is ultimately preaching a world
that is destructive what are you leaving
for your children to grow up in I just I
I like I just to hammer and reiterate
the reason why I think James O'Keefe is
is seeing so many people stand up is
that they've realized when that the this
is the deal with the Devil of course
it's going to help your family of course
your kids will eat food and you are
scared about what happens the the the
the the deal will never just be to give
you a convertible because think about
the bargaining power of of of again
figurative or literal the Devil comes to
you with a bar with a deal what leverage
does he have to say I can give you a
Ferrari or an infinity pool none you're
going to be like I'm going to give you
my soul for wealth what does that mean
to me then he goes and says your
children will die unless you sign in
blood my contract they say I will I will
do anything you say that's right that's
right I mean it's that Elon kind of
rejected that premise a few weeks ago
didn't he with with Disney he you're
blackmail me with money and I think
that's that's person that's the
personification of this movement I mean
whistleblowing you know it's it's uh uh
people people going against the the idea
of a social contract people inside the
corporation the presence of the outside
on the inside these people are i' i'
again Tim I've never seen anything like
this I mean I would I would be perusing
my DMs for a week and I might get a
couple interesting I work inside this
company but it's
just like like clockwork and I think
it's Elon I think it's X I think it's
the platform people I can't believe that
people in the government are just
sliding into my DMs I'm like dude at
least use signal or something but
they'll just DM me on Instagram be like
I work for the DHS that's good you know
why why is that because people are no
longer scared right that the the
mentality is we have broken the dam we
are winning we are winning culturally
and I will no longer serve evil do you
think any of it has to do with the
timing of the election like there's one
year left might as well come forward now
I don't think it's there's one year left
isn't that crazy I don't just I don't
think you just mean about Biden's
presidency I think who knows what I mean
whether it's a year away or a year and
three months away no something is
happening it might be the Elon thing
elon's speech to Disney it's a
Confluence of events um but the IBM
story we did i' I've never ever seen the
CEO of IBM there was was on tape saying
some things he shouldn't have said about
Asians and then he gets on an all staff
Call with IBM he says no this James
o'keef video do not respond to the video
do not give a reaction everyone and then
that was leaked to me by 10 people so
and they can't fire they can't fire they
they can whack them all one person but
if you
have8 leaks it's actually impossible for
HR with an IBM to do anything about your
ship is just thinking your ship is I
mean your exactly you got water coming
out of this hole that hole there's
nothing they can do yeah you know when a
Dam breaks it usually is pretty
destructive and when like a Sie if you
Sie a balloon and it pops that's
essentially the pretty powerful
explosive force seemingly do you are you
concerned with what might happen if
these corporations rupture from the
inside or I think it's happening and
I've been thinking about this I'm kind
of a victim of my own success I'm trying
to figure out how to manage this dam
breaking and and how it can be leveraged
for for for good I mean it's always been
a crisis of conscience with the
Whistleblower because you have to betray
betray your your colleagues your
corporation your employer for the
Public's right to know the information
and now it seems people are so fed up so
fed up like with this immigration thing
I was just talking about here people
getting you know refugees everyone's a
refugee crossing the border here's a
free airplane ticket no security go fly
somewhere and now you can vote and buy a
gun I mean it's just I mean it's so it's
so crazy it's like an SNL satire that
perhaps the American people saying I'm
I'm I'm I can't do this pilot saying and
talking to Ashley you should talk to
actually too she's inundated with Pilots
are they going to stop Flying the
airplanes I I remember back when the
mandates were were on Pilots were also a
lot a lot of Pilots are starting to
stand up I think what we are seeing over
the past several years culturally we are
winning more and more people I mean
simply look at Donald Trump's polling
okay Trump is is not a saint Trump is
not your hero but a singular reflection
a a a Nexus point of the sentiment of
the people people who did not vote in
2020 swing heavily towards Donald Trump
that indicates that a lot of people not
and and again I'm not saying Trump
saying but a lot of people are apprised
of what is happening to this country and
the world and this is also indicative of
more whistleblowers more people stepping
up more people refusing to play ball in
in the machines game it feels like in a
way it feels like people that are like
I've had enough of this system let's
let's expose it and call it out it's
kind of like that moment in Indiana
Jones where he's about to take the idol
off the thing but they don't have a bag
of sand to put on they just take the
idol like they're I'm done with it I
just can't imagine being a like
18-year-old voter this year right when
you're 10 to like Middle School whatever
life is pretty good gas press down
Trump's in office then you hit 14 covid
Biden says all kinds of crazy stuff he
falls down constantly we're on the brink
of war in like three different places
and then you're 18 you're like I don't
want to votee for this guy again this is
bad well the majority of whistleblowers
in in the 20th century I think suffered
an obscurity and and as Jeffrey wgan is
a great example that was a 60 Minutes
guy who blew the whistle on nicotine big
tobacco and his marriage ended his
mortgage ended he was he was sued he had
Security death threats but if but if if
this the reverse effect is now happening
it's not the Whistleblower who's being
targeted and subjected there's this
weird inversion that is happening it's
the it's the guy who's the CEO of IBM
who's now who's now being subjected to
online comments and who's facing
pressure so there's this inversion in
power and the social pressures are
actually like with Dei and now we have
this new uh Tim you've pulled up this
graphic let me pull up the story uh a
tweet from James O'Keefe James do you
want to uh uh read this out and explain
what's going on yeah so this is a you're
looking at here I don't think anyone has
reported this at least our team has not
been able to find this on the internet
if I'm if I stand corrected let me know
this is breaking news from Phoenix Sky
Harbor airport this week you're looking
at a a ticket counter piece of paper um
this is given to immigrants illegal
immigrants coming in the United States
they they ship them from different parts
of Arizona to a Welcome Center a School
in Phoenix and then they're picked up in
limousines I'm not you I'm not making
this up black cars that's an inside joke
black cars by the way did you know
nonprofit are not allowed to hire black
cars it's against IRS rules but these
nonprofits yes I'm just I'm making a
joke ah uh project baratas joke there um
so these immigrants are picked up in
black cars and dropped off at the
airport and these are documents that
were given to me by various airport
insiders it says quote please help me
print my boarding pass I am a refugee
and I do not speak the language thank
you we redacted the confirmation number
there to protect The Insider at the
airport and a lot of the these
immigrants are not from Mexico they're
from all different countries across
across the world uh the government
claims it's vetting these individuals
prior to putting them up on planes but
we're reporting that uh a lot of The
Insider tips contradict that we found
that agents responsible for vetting the
identification are relying solely on
their word and they don't speak English
so it's it's fascinating here Tim and
and I and just a backtrack for a minute
uh for the audience I was I was outside
this airport the airline insiders
confirm red me oh my gosh James O'Keefe
you have to help us every 30 minutes the
buses pull up I interviewed the bus
driver he said he was with a company
called jet limousines and then we were
able to figure out where they pick these
people up it's at a Welcome Center in
Phoenix Arizona and they hire these car
services to drop them off the airports
and they're shipped across the country
New Jersey New York and places like that
and technically I think you would call
that smuggling them across the country
you might you might call that smuggling
I under attack I followed up with Maran
Williamson last night whose brother we
talked about immigration a bit and her
brother does immigration uh he's a
lawyer and said that her brother said
that each of these individuals should be
receiving a what's called a credible
fear interview and if you cannot
establish that they have legitimate
credible fear you send them back
immediately you cannot take people we we
haven't done that for years right the
thing about the border is that this has
been an issue for decades and every
political party has flipped up it Bill
Clinton in his like 1995 State of the
Union Address said every American should
be concerned about the number of illegal
immigrants coming across the border and
instead we just left a broken system to
get worse and worse and worse no wonder
airline pilots and all sorts of
community members are frustrated by this
I just think it's really funny that this
like Turning Point sent all of these
conservative people to Arizona while
this was happening and everyone in the
airport was noticing this right I mean
that was the thing Ashley was there for
it you were there for that our crew who
flew through Chicago on their way saw
the same thing in Chicago so we before
even getting to TP USA we're getting
messages from our crew being like Hey
we're on a plane it's all illegal
immigrants like all they've got the bags
that and I'm and we're like wow and then
they're being dropped off in Chicago the
East Coast I I get hundreds of these
messages from people and say they I
can't say who they are hey this is my
throwaway account I set up a fake X
don't reveal my name so I don't get in
trouble but I know the location that we
drop off migrants from neales Tucson
Yumi here in Phoenix so they all can go
to Phoenix Sky Harbor and uh they drop
them off at this school this this
Welcome Center this school now turned
Welcome Center we get hundreds of people
coming in and uh and anyway I'm going
back to Phoenix to to follow up on this
because this is a fascinating story and
they have all these car companies that
they hire I'm trying to figure out who's
doing this is the feds the state there's
a lot more paying for it who's paying
for it and by the way one more thing
about this Tim this whistle blowing let
me just add that there's nowhere for
these people to actually these insiders
to go obviously they can't go to the New
York Times yep cuz they'll hunt those
people down like a trophy buck and print
their real name but but there's no one
you got to have guts to publish these
stories you know and uh citizen
journalism here I think it is not
hyperbole to say the 2024 election is or
is the last
election we until the next one no I mean
it in terms of what this country is this
is it however however only if Joe Biden
or the Democrats win and I don't think
it's hyperbolic um when you look at
what's going on the federal government
has been
facilitating
the mass illegal migration into this
country to the point where black
residents in Chicago are on video right
now screaming this this no joke an
elderly black man got up at at a meeting
and said Trump get in here and clean
this mess up I'm like wow when the
Chicago black community is so fed up
with the abuse they're yelling for a
republican that's how bad it's gotten if
the Democrats win in 24 we will not
survive four more years of 10,000 plus
illegal immigrants every day what is
your hypothesis that are they going to
let let uh them Vote or what do you
think you mentioned something about
camps in Boston recently uh Boston
recently passed a bill for non-citizens
to vote New York has had similar
Provisions uh cities in California have
had similar Provisions yes we are we are
Marching towards we are a couple years
away if the Democrats win non-citizens
illegal immigrants will will be slowly
granted voting powers and they're all
considered refugees because they can
just claim that I guess anybody can
claim to be a refugee I probably should
go to Mexico and just slide I mean this
is dangerous but wear a hidden camera
and just go across the border and
disguise and just go through the whole
process that would be a good idea if we
have any brave people that want to sign
up on the OMG website what would happen
if the US brought in 15 million illegal
immigrants mostly fighting age males and
then just load them up on boats and ship
them off to like the Taiwan like to
Taiwan and been like okay now now you
defend this place but Democrats would
never let that happen because we use
illegal immigrants to throw off the
census data right remember when Trump
was like I would like the immigration
status to be on the census and
citizenship status and they were like
absolutely not that's crazy you're so
racist well I wonder why right like this
is something that is the the only reason
someone would allow for this to happen
is if they benefit it for benefit from
it in some way and that's the issue here
right all of the illegal immigrants
especially those who are actually you
know smuggled brutalized brought across
really dangerous and restrictive
terrible conditions I mean there was a
story two months ago about a shipping
container full of I think it was 60
people who were all dead they were being
trafficked across the border this is a
brutal problem for everyone involved
right I don't think you should cross
into the country illegally but I also
think that by incentivizing illegal
immigrations by saying if you get here
we'll just put you on an airplane and
send you wherever you want to go we are
making all kinds of people take crazy
risk that we shouldn't encourage I I
think it it could happen that a bunch 15
million immigrants come across illegally
and then get shipped off to Taiwan to
defend the island or to either Ukraine
to defend Ukraine but then they'd still
get their census tally at whatever state
they were in before they got shipped out
and then they get their citizenship if
they survive if you're an illegal you
put in State this is one of the issues
right so if you come across the boorder
illegally they'll say you have a court
date it's in three years from now but
then you never go to that court date so
I don't know how we would then recall
all of the people we allowed in
illegally you'd have to immediately send
them and we we aren't good at that we'd
rather send them wherever they want to
go in the US even though they don't have
keep this pretty I I keep my reporting
pretty factual without making judgments
how do you handle I do see about 20% of
comments uh you know that kind of the
empathy people have for these poor
people who are in a horrible place just
trying to have a better life how do you
deal with that talking point from people
these poor people want have a better
life yeah that that type of thing you
get I I welcome them with open arms I
hope every poor person in the world who
wants to come to America comes to
America through the legal process
properly right and that legal process
means it might take them 20 years but
they're all welcome to apply and uh join
our community done right why uh you get
this talking point like Maran Williamson
said the other day migrants are a boost
to the economy and like yes you are
absolutely correct when managed properly
right when they when we bring migrants
in like we did she says how many of your
grandparents you know were migrants and
I'm like right when they arrived on
Ellis Island and said now we will
integrate and we will assimilate and be
like the Americans that's not what
they're doing today today they're
cutting the the razor wire saying
everybody quick run and they're dumping
these people in Chicago where they have
nowhere to go and now Chicago's like
we're going to build mass
camps okay look what do you call large
camps and I mean this a literal question
not a rhetorical one what do you call
large camps where they house a part like
a political faction of people you know
the problem is I don't want to say
concentration camp because everyone just
immediately thinks Nazi Germany I am not
arguing for prison or death camps but
quite literally they are going to create
migrant detention camps these people are
being shipped in in Chicago and they're
putting up they're building fences and
and I think one of them got delayed but
they're putting them in schools they're
putting them in police stations I if
Trump wins in 2024 I can already tell
you what 2025 is going to look like
Donald there's going to be videos of
people being loaded up onto trains onto
buses and sent to camps for deportation
and the left is going to Screech like
banshees he's Hitler it's happening
again Heaven me quick everyone take up
your arms they want it's it's it's 4D
chess across the board right everybody
is playing some Advanced strategy of
Victory lawsuits are being prepared and
what we're seeing today will have
massive impacts in the next two or three
years and longer obviously throughout
the history of this country or what's
left of it but what's being done today
there is a plan for what comes next yeah
I I told you guys this I think you and
Michael mice the other night I Einstein
when the Nazis were coming to power he
saw it early and got out of the country
and fled to the United States and
already fled the US I am I'm feeling
that right now and I don't like that but
that is what I feel and what I see is
like yo if Mass illegal immigration
record high inflation World Wars all
popping up all over the place the people
arresting their political opponents like
okay guys and I don't want to blackpill
you and I don't want to give up on this
wonderful Constitution we got but what
is the country even mean is it the land
that you live on is it the Constitution
that's bit is it the people that are
running the milit like what is this
country I mean that's the question right
I don't know where you would like to go
if you were to leave the us one of the
issu Salvador El Salvador maybe I mean
there are interesting places one of the
issues is countries are built on a sense
of patriotism in a sense of community
and loyalty right and so you would
theoretically want to stay and fix it on
the other hand I understand the instinct
to be like it's it's just going up in
Flames I I need to leave and I think
that there are people who immigrated to
the us from their own countries legally
immigrated here who made the same
decision and I wonder what their
conversation is like right now do we
stay in the us where we went for a
better life or and try and fix it I met
a guy at MGM National Harbor playing
poker and uh you know you're at the
poker table you're you're shooting a
you're talking and he mentioned he
was from El Salvador and I was like oh I
hear it's uh I hear it's getting really
really good down there this was a few
months ago and he goes yeah actually my
family's moving back you're going back
to El Salvador he's like yeah crime is
weigh down the economy is doing really
well so my family wants to go home
better to be a poor farmer than a medal
in the politics how was the first
amendment in El Salvador I I don't know
the politics of that they have a article
three courts protect the first I think
it's a very important thing in the
United States I think the the issue is
is not about the constitution in the
first amendment when we had free speech
in the 70s they still arrested George
Carlin for swearing the the the issue is
do you have good leaders and so my view
is I I I i' believe that naib belli
would respect legitimate journalistic
Endeavors who's that he's the current
president although I'm not going to
pretend to know enough about the the
government functions and guaranteed
rights they the the corporate president
of the United States argued that he was
a despit for arresting all these gang
members and cartel members and things
like that but you know spare me these
people are the New York Times Are
grotesque monsters yes I mean I think
that's the next that's one of the tests
that we're going to find here in this
year is is is the limits of the First
Amendment because you you talk about
camps in Chicago I I that may be true
but if that is true I guarantee you
there's going to be video inside of
there and things leaking like a Civ
we're going to get so much information I
think I think what you're going to see
this year it's going to be horrible
that's the bad news the good news is all
the horrible things will be captured on
video and leaked to the world but my
concern is deep fakes what's coming I
think that see everyone always talks
about Ai and and if I knew the solution
about AI I'd be I'd be a billionaire
because everyone wants to know the
solution to AI but I think the
discipline of verification has been a
thing that's been there for 100 years
you have to check things out you have to
verify look
man
the a year and a half ago I made a deep
fake of Nancy Pelosi and it was a
grotesque disgusting P picture and it
was hilarious a year later AI is so good
you can make a photo realistic picture
of Nancy Pelosi when it comes to video
verification is not the issue and I'll
tell you I'll give you the
example Donald Trump stands up at a
rally and says you had very fine people
on both sides and I am not talking about
the white supremacists because they
should be condemned totally we know that
video we know the media manipulated and
cut out of context what Trump said he
said I am not talking about the Nazis
and the white nationalists they should
be condemned totally the Deep fake issue
is not going to be a video of Donald
Trump saying something racist the Deep
fake video I'm scared of is Donald Trump
saying almost 90 99% Verbatim what he
did say but what they'll do is they'll
change it so whereas Trump actually said
and they should be condemned totally the
Deep fake version will go some of them
should be condemned totally and then no
one will know which one is the original
video because they're near identical the
left will say some of them should be
condemned oh man he's saying some of the
nazzis are good and then you'll argue no
no no he didn't actually say some of
that a deep fake no you're lying you
made the Deep fake Trump was defending
them right Biden already launched his
campaign off that lie and so that's one
example
of the fear a single word being changed
I see and it will be weaponized and
there's no verification of it also like
a presidential address could be deep
Fair do you guys remember when Jim aosta
tried ripping the mic out of the hand of
that White House Aid mhm and the country
was split half of people were like she
tried ripping the mic from Jim a Costa's
hand and then the other half was like
aosta tried ripping the mic from her
hand and no one knew for
sure I think it's fair to say and there
were all these deep analysis videos
drawing lines and like figuring out it's
fairly obvious that Jim aosta was was
pulling the mic to try he was trying to
hold it and she was she was she grabbed
it and then he jerk to try and pull it
back from her because he was trying to
yell at Trump but either way you have a
video and no one agrees what happened
yeah but they had to kind of quote
George Carlin when he talked about the
World Plus plastic there will be a new
paradigm where that will be what you
just describ will be happening to
everyone and if that is true to DOTA
Trump then both sides will do it you
mentioned something about so there'll
just be a new paradigm where where
people will distrust things a little
more perhaps and and journalism is all
about trust and and who do you trust but
but I still I still stand by my
statement the discipline of verification
is something that existed before video I
mean people in newspapers report
according to people familiar with the
matter and they're reporting anonymously
sourced statements that we don't have
video of right so don't those journalism
rules apply to this new era when
everything is question
people will simply choose what confirms
their bias okay so with these with deep
fakes getting as good as they are yeah
you're gonna you're going to say hold on
was Trump even really at that rally and
then you'll pull up the video and you'll
be like okay Trump really was there did
he actually say this there's two
versions of the same event you imagine
Riot and then they deep fix somebody
into the riot and then that person gets
arrested for being at the riot January 6
like that yeah stuff like that let let
me let me ask you has this is the
reality of politics and a low Trust
about a posttruth society we there if if
a police officer says you broke the law
you did good luck good luck I was you
you go to court and you get a speeding
ticket and you say your honor I wasn't
speeding the cop says your honor he was
speeding guess what you lose that's it I
mentioned to you at uh in Miami at the
event that we did the IRL event that I
thought o'keef Media Group a cool thing
to do would be to build some technology
that can identify deep fakes because
you've got the trust and that would be
cool coming from you and your
organization or an organization that you
work with I think trust is is is
critical journalis journalistic trust
they trust me why because of what I've
been through and there are other people
they trust too but I think that's that's
critical I think I don't know enough
about technology to build that but it's
a good idea but I also think here's one
thing they can't fake the person on the
inside going public the courageous thing
that can't be a fake if someone says I
work for the IRS the lowest learner or I
work for the FBI or I work for this
institution and you know what I'm
jumping on a grenade from my country
that that's a real thing thing isn't it
and then there's a reaction from the
institution there's always well could
counter oper counter Intel Ops and
things like that there is there is I
mean there is I mean you're talking
about a totally fake World we're totally
post I'm a little bit more of an
optimist I believe there is one truth it
can be verified through multiple sources
like if one guy sends you a video of
another he basically acts as if he's
someone else how many how many how many
people think you are a farri they've
been saying that for 20 years but they
stopped stop using those words recently
do they say a doctor tapes that Tim they
used say 10 years ago remember that he's
the tape doctor he he doctors the tape
I'm like can you just name one by the
way I have no money I'm using Final Cut
seven I wish I knew how to they said
with the acorn story that I put CGI to
make the people's lips move I'm like I
don't even know how to put the font
other than Cur you know Curry or new but
the last 24 hours of my life here's what
I did I had people message me from jet
limo another jet limo five sources and I
was corroborating the information I had
by talking to multiple sources inside
the company to verify that guy was the
real person's name this is what
journalists do they they verify
information by getting multiple accounts
of the version of events to ensure that
the thing that they're looking at is
real I think that's what ethical
journalists do and that's no no one does
that anymore that's what I mean there's
nobody has the time and it's laziness
it's incompetence it's it's a lack of
usually it's economics but my point is
that video of me talking to the bus
driver if if that wasn't my video which
it was but he said I work for jet
limousine I do face check.id I find his
picture online there's his LinkedIn I
talk to his colleague I talk to his boss
then I publish the video so I verifi
that the video that I've taken is real
and that does you're right that doesn't
happen anymore and on social media I
feel like and maybe I'm biased but like
conservative moderate journalists would
maybe take all those steps but someone
who is trying to smear someone says I
don't care if it's not real in fact I
would prefer if you do not follow up
with me at all do not see that I have
not or they paint or they paint the New
York Times reporters paint this
elaborate using words like document show
how far the conservative group would go
to not run a foul of the law another way
of saying that is we check with our
lawyers to make sure what we do is legal
but they make it word it in such a way
or like this person who has been accused
of doctoring T based on some random you
know blog post from the internet that is
also not verified that has no backup
then site that it's just repeating the
LIE making it bigger I mean it's the
idea of like basically being a Google
felon right false information report
about you that becomes part of the
circularly sourced information yes
Wikipedia if you got a video and they're
like this guy said This Racist stuff at
the company this this executive and then
it it it turns out to be a deep face
yeah yeah I see what you're saying how
do you verify that one of the ways you
verify it for example is getting it from
two different sources from two different
angles and you know there are different
way I mean there's no hard and fast
there's no hard and fast rule on how to
verify the thing but I tell my reporters
if you put a gun to your mother's head
are you 100% sure that that that that's
true before you report it and that's the
standard and Tim I mean it's a good
point it's worth discussing I I just uh
I I think I I I there's got to be a way
in this posttruth world to verify that
what you're looking at is real there are
people who care about the truth and want
to know and we'll verify and I think
those are the people who are on our side
yeah they'll be there are Mindless
zealots who don't care I mean did you
see Hassan P's response to Ashley stair
no I I didn't he made this
ridiculous low IQ tweet where he was
like oh my God foreigners are flying on
planes how could this possibly happen oh
my God send help and all of his fans are
laughing and clapping for him because
it's it like when you got mindless
drones who don't know or don't care
there there there are two kinds of
people in this world I mean the truth is
there's like a ton of different kinds of
people but right now you've got the
people who are more independently minded
and they're they're wondering what am I
doing and and is it right and then you
have the other group that says I just
want to have the Pitchfork and be in the
mob that's it yeah I think 2024 it's the
year to focus on the people that care
about the truth and the other people are
just going to be friction let me let me
pull up the story here from Politico
Trump allies and Maga luminaries mov to
kill off the Haley for VP Buzz Haley's
rise as prompted speculation should' be
a logical running mate for Trump this is
fake news this is an absolutely fake
story and I'm willing to bet that uh
these two people who wrote it f
fabricated it through clever
manipulation what I mean by that is you
take a morsel of truth and you can make
it mean whatever you want it to mean you
can make it convey whatever you want to
convey take a look at this the fervent
effort to kill off Haley's V Buzz before
it truly takes off has come from the
former as the former un Ambassador next
South Carolina governor is gaining
momentum in Republican primary it is
prompted speculation she'd be a logical
Choice as a running mate for Trump who
has maintained a wide polling lead blah
blah blah horiz has caught the attention
of the former president who has recently
quizzed people outside his campaign for
their impressions of Haley according to
three people familiar with the
conversation quote what do you think of
Nikki Trump had asked It's Not Unusual
for Trump to survey donors outside adver
outside advisers and members of his Mar
Lago Resort on Personnel matters he's
also blah blah blah blah blah what do
they say um he pressed allies for the
impressions of other Republicans etc etc
but Haley has been the subject of his
most recent Focus Haley's polling surge
has alarmed some staunch Trump trump
confidants who are acutely aware the
former president pays close attention to
survey dat data etc etc so they're
referencing uh during a phone
conversation with one Ally about Haley
Trump indicated that he was aware of the
criticisms of her but nonetheless wanted
to get this person's take about the
former Ambassador according to a person
familiar with the call here's what
likely really happened Donald Trump
probably called someone and said yeah
I'm hearing a lot of people in the media
talking about it we how how are you
doing these journalists then say the
reason why Trump is not quoted here if
someone truly came to them three people
apparently familiar with this call you'd
think they would go Donald Trump said in
fact there is an earlier quote what do
you think of Nikki Trump had asked
where's the rest of what he said why
because they they don't want to get sued
right so the I always explain this to
people the media will lie when they ask
you for when they ask you for a quote no
matter what you say they will find a way
to make it the narrative they want for
example a journalist contacts James
o'keef and says want to write a story
about you as a profile I'm curious
what's your take on dogs and then James
says I love Love Dogs I think dogs are
fantastic who doesn't love dogs and
they'll go oo that's a quote we can't
run I got an idea when asked about
whether James o'keef liked dogs he asked
an intriguing question seemingly
confused indicating in fact he may not
actually like dogs at all when they
don't use quotes they're lying to you
well this like what do you think of
Haley they don't say really anything
other than it's on this supposed call I
mean it could you could easily pull it
from like a rally like what if Trump
walked out of rally and was like what do
you guys think of Nicki Haley and they
all booed right like this anything it's
so Random Trump could have been on the
phone with Steve Bannon who knows and
then he's like yeah I saw what Tucker
said about Haley as if anyone actually
cares what do you think about Haley as
if anyone's going to ask that question
and they run that quote specifically out
of context to make it seem like Donald
Trump actually wants what do you think
of Haley she I think she's about to
cancel her campaign said Trump he might
have said he might have said uh I've
heard a bunch of criticism about her
what do you think about her the way
like I don't know and he's like all
right the way I look at this is a a
journalism professor said many years ago
he said the way you deal with these is
every time they use these so this is
anonymously sourced here according to
people familiar with the matter the way
I see it is it you need more of your
stories to produce actual evidence like
over 51% should be documents or video
but this is like the New York Times is
usually 95 to 100% anonymously material
so it's like taking money out of an ATM
I have to deposit into my bank account
because I'm withdrawing upon my own
journalistic credibility if I'm going to
say trust me by virtue of the decree
that I'm to be trusted I Tim's right I
have no reason to trust those two guys
that story I'll give you I'll give you a
a an example of what may have happened
let's say that quote from Trump is real
so Trump's on the phone uh after uh the
last GOP debate and he goes man Ron's
campaign is not doing too well uh I'm
seeing he's down in the polls and then
they're like yep he he is crashing and
burning and then Trump goes I think
they're all crashing and burning what do
you think about Haley they take that
quote and turn it into Donald Trump was
curious about Haley's a VP pick because
he asked what do you think about Haley
it could have been in the context of him
mocking the failure of other campaigns
we don't know and I get this emails all
the time the very last second or even
like while they're publishing the story
they send me the New York Times sends me
this whole thing and I I call them up on
the phone and record it and they hang up
the phone I'm try I mean I well here's a
tactic that you should do if you ever
get asked for comment by the media um uh
publish your statement to your entire
audience before they go to air their
story that there's nothing they can do
because you've made it clear okay World
here's my response now I have a a pretty
large following many people don't but
that's what what Trump could do but I I
think the challenge I agree but the
challenge is Politico knows our audience
doesn't care about political articles
that's true and the people who read
Politico are lwi information individuals
no Tim your point about the the the
world being segmented where you're only
playing to your audience is is a very
good point and and I get that it's not
just only to to your audience it's you
know the the the side that we are on is
not the quote unquote right you can call
whatever you want I don't think it is I
I think it's just good and evil true and
false at this point yes agreed they call
you right wing but you don't come out
and and and Advocate policy no never
you're like here here's a here's a
politician saying a thing and they're
like ah he's right wing it's like hold
on if he was coming out saying I'm
opposed to these policies in favor of
these policies so vote this person I
have opinions on politics all day every
day yeah so if they want to accuse me of
something fine I get it but but I think
it is the Liars the top down control and
the ignorant versus those who want
freedom meritocracy honesty truth Etc
yeah I try to keep it I try to keep it
very factual actually there's plenty of
facts to there's plenty of factually
things to say but that that that's
fascinating kind of I love this sort of
master class and going through an
article and one of the things that they
also do is they'll they'll send me
they'll send me an article say you
please please comment and then I'll give
them a comment that's quite material to
the circumstance and they'll say James
O'Keefe did not respond to what we was
asked about well it's like print what I
want print what I said if you really
want to have fairness which is all these
journalists do but um I I think um yeah
I think it's a it's a great exercise
going through this like you're doing
yeah I think if journalists maybe if
they want to get comments from now on it
should be live the comments should be
live it should all be on a chat thing on
a website where it happens in real time
you can't talk to them look you if if if
they come to you and and like again
using the dog analogy if they said um do
you support uh the working class and you
go absolutely I support the working
class instead of running your quote
they'll say Ian sarcastically mocked
workingclass people and asked if he
supported them and you'll be like no I
didn't I said I supported them and
they'll be like yeah sarcastically yeah
I think the age of relying on someone
else to to represent you is over man you
got to represent yourself I mean one of
the other issues is that if you feel
like you can't talk to the Press right
they'll go to the person who will feel
like they can talk to them which is
typically someone who feels like they
have a friendly relationship with the
publication so you're getting a bias
Viewpoint because someone who's like I
don't trust you you're always trying to
represent me in a negative way you're
always saying I hate the working class
whatever they're ultimately going to
pull away until the narrative becomes
more insulated that way yeah one of the
things that they do is they they they
call themselves credible there was one
story we did so Anderson Cooper this guy
from The Washington Post Jacob B is his
name he literally looks like humpty
dumpy he's got his oval face and and
bagage says well Anderson we're credible
journalists so they say we're credible
credible sources so they they rely upon
this virtue that they've assigned to the
themselves that they are credible by
virtue of their own decree that they are
that way and and their anonymously
sourced stuff is permitted to contradict
incontrovertible evidence and that's why
I go back to this trust thing it's just
the experts the credible sources and now
but you're making a good point point
with in is incontrovertible evidence
incontrovertible because it could be
Manu it could be a deep fate well I
think I think the issue is you're right
about verification our side will always
appreciate verification sourcing and
will seek out those they can trust those
who are willing I hate saying that it's
our but there is a a group of people
it's a way of behavior it's a way of
behavior values there are people who
look this is why we like Marian
Williamson and when we're grateful that
you came on because she is a good person
and I believe she is an honest person
she uh openly talked about her views but
she gets her news from Bad sources not
anymore not after last night well it
improves and that's why we're grateful
she comes on but when when I when uh it
was a really amazing moment last night
when we showed Marian Williamson the
whiteness contract from the book not my
idea she almost cried she had never seen
it before and so she's getting this
narrative about banning books and she
like our Republicans are crazy but the
problem with Marian's source of
information is that she's likely hearing
secondhand opinions from someone who
watched CNN and MSNBC whereas James is
actually recording people saying the
words yeah and Publishing them she then
hears her friend go oh James o'e
fabricated that video and she goes wow
then when she gets to a political debate
someone says didn't you see the video
from James O'Keefe I shouldn't say Maran
but the liberal will then go he
fabricated that there are going to be a
substantial minority of people whose
Minds have actually been changed like I
hired this named Jason Watkins he's a
professor at a ASU journalism School Tim
he teaches journalism at the kronite
school he used to be a leftist his mind
was actually Chang I'm not am I making
this up my colle people think y that's
insane there are people who actually do
change their minds and if 5% or 1% let's
just call it 1% of people change their
minds or their hearts then then one
would even argue if one person changes
their mind that you've made a difference
so I don't think you need to affect the
majority of people and of course there
some people say it's fake thing but you
know all right here we go not not being
angry too is a real big part I bet the
founding fathers weren't angry guys they
strike me as like really level-headed
dudes no some of them were super angry
but it's it's yeah uh I'm going to pull
this tweet here let's roll Will
Chamberlain tweeted out a quote from
Nikki Haley in 2020 saying we should all
stand with Bubba Wallace today against
the cowards who secretly put the Noose
in his garage stall watch your back
cowards Bubba has a bigger Army than you
do
cringe well we all know about Nikki
Haley's cringe but Will Chamberlain said
meet Trump's VP pick I responded I'll
bet you $1,000 he doesn't pick Haley
Will Chamberlain replies give me four to
one odds and you're on my response if
Trump picks Haley I'll give you
$4,000 if he picks anyone else you give
me
$1,000 uh will responded and if it's a
it's a push if Trump doesn't win win the
nod if so deal and I said let's get it
bets on and and he said all right bet I
am so confident I actually don't know if
it's a real bet or we were just joking
to be completely honest no it's real
it's in writing contract the world's
going to hold you to it like for for
sure for sure uh like and I'll stand by
it if it is real but um I will may have
been trolling and I'm goofing off but
you know in the end it'll be funny if
when will comes on the show and then we
can you know when when depending on what
happens if uh Trump doesn't or does will
will resolve it but my point with this
is not to actually say I want to bet
cash it's just that I'm so confident
Donald Trump will not pick Nikki Haley
that I'm willing to make a bet I'll have
to I'll have to talk to Will and ask him
if he was serious about it but it's fun
anyway and I will you know if it is but
uh I'm so confident that I'm not worried
about four to one odds yeah the thing is
the the Nikki Haley VP rumor I feel like
is just the mainstream media trying
desperately to say it has influence over
the conservative primary or the
Republican primary I think ultimately we
know that she is not the VP choice I
obviously think I've said this a couple
times on the show I think one of the
mistakes we make is thinking that the
only options for VP are the people we
see on the debate stage there's actually
a much deeper deck of potential people
anyone could pick from uh it doesn't
just happen to be the who else do launch
a presidential campaign but I think you
know there's too much bad blood between
Nikki Haley and uh Donald Trump and I
don't think she would Garner him any
major support anywhere he needs it is
that like I didn't know they had bad
blood do they not get along yeah they've
sniped each other a ton yeah he doesn't
seem to enjoy working with people that
he's sniped with I mean why would you
right this we're talking about trust all
night tonight plus Tucker so this is
would you have taken 10 to one odds is
what I want to know uh Tucker said on
stage at turning point he would actually
Advocate against that ticket if Trump
picked Haley he would say Do not vote
for Trump so I I think Trump listens to
Tucker that's why I'm on board I don't
think there's any chance in hell he's
going to go with Nikki Haley at this
point uh Tucker suggested he pick viic
ramaswami I also suggested that I think
that he would be the right move Ram
Swami said he wouldn't take a VP pick
when he was here with us when jamus was
on um I don't know that was that was a
smart tactic if you're running for
president you shouldn't say I'll accept
second place but realistically I think
uh I think that would be because I mean
whoever becomes VP is probably going to
be the next president I'd rather see V
go back to Ohio and run for office there
and do something interesting I mean he's
got so much energy I feel like in some
ways being VP would be too penned in for
him although in the age of social media
and he's a loud mouth in a good way V uh
like he would make a lot of noise in
that office and I think Trump's a li
he's his life is liable like if he tries
to be president again it's a very
dangerous place for his life sure and
he's got a lot of civil civil cases
going on I mean there are a lot of
things calling his attention so I I
would say that that that VP role is
probably more important now than it's
been in my lifetime in 44 years that's
probably the most likely that a VP would
become president which is why Charlie
Kirk suggested it's the right move would
be to make Tucker Carlson the VP and
Tucker was humble about it but what do
you think about that Tucker wanted Ian
to be pres vice president yeah he agreed
I thought I thought was talking about me
tuck well Charlie said who it should be
is the man sitting next to me and I was
sitt and I was like oh well thank you
Charlie and Tucker was like I'd vote for
that but do you think Tucker does poor
Tucker know yeah do you think he'd be a
good VP do I think he'd be I I mean
there there's a difference between um
journalism and governing but maybe he
could do it I mean he certainly got the
got the uh the popularity and and the
people and the goodwi of the people and
that's what you need who do you think
should BEP who I don't have an opinion
on the matter I I actually think that
Tim is very brave for placing because I
think all bets are off I think it's
impossible to predict what is going to
happen I mean I if if aliens if Flying
Saucer came through this window that
would not surprise me right now I think
Biden information would come crazy to
clarify it's safe to tweet this because
I will even said he was trolling uh a
different tweet so I don't know if we
there's any actual real bet I see I see
but but my point is like like I would
make the bad I don't know depending on
whatever but I need to actually ask Will
like did you really
want the laws on like making a bet like
that I don't even know tax it's Monopoly
money he can come there taxes for like
you know bet with your friends I don't
know maybe over Lim he he said that when
he was saying Nikki when he said Trump
was going to pick Nikki Haley he was
like obviously trolling he he said that
oh oh okay like he's poking fun at Trump
for the idea that he might pick Haley
that Bubba wall tweet tweet is awful so
badly can't be Dan sis it won't be Dan
sis I I think Tucker would be a good
probably a good pick and I think you
would accept if Trump asked him I think
Charlie's right on that analysis you
know I think Tucker could help Trump win
but you make a good point about
journalism versus and commentary versus
actual governance being a good political
leader it's not about knowing the issues
that's a component of it it's about
knowing how to navigate and IEM really
like VI's move with strive his company
that's divesting away from ESG this is
what turned me onto him in the very
beginning when I first met him I didn't
know who he was Tim interviewed him I
think it was Charlie Kirk's studio and I
was just like this guy knows how to
solve the problem the problem is Black
Rock is trying to buy up the world and
he knows how to divest our our resources
away from Black Rock by not complaining
he's creating a new system for some
reason and I don't necessarily agree
with this I'm just telling you what is
is the realities for some reason the
people don't trust Vic or they're asking
who is this person they many people in
the midwest have said is he like it's
like Obama this very very very uh
intelligent well spoken guy but they
don't they just don't seem to trust him
or know know him well enough like they
for example trust Tucker that's that's
the read I'm seeing by the way I I like
most of what vvec says I I interviewed
vbec and him and I had great chemistry I
he's ridiculously smart I like what he
says I um he he even understood what I
do to a degree that most people don't
but for some reason the people don't
seem to to do see that they don't seem
to like who is this guy think that's
because he's sort of well clearly
they're racist out of nowhere well well
don't throw the race card around we're
too close the end of the year no I mean
serious he sort of popped out of nowhere
I mean a lot of people didn't know what
his company did he wrote his book you
know it's all very fast that's why I I
really do think if he were to you know
be the governor of Ohio he can build
this this uh you know National name a
little bit more but also you know really
take Ohio to an I mean you're from Ohio
right like he could do so much for that
state and also eventually launch another
presidential bid I think it would be
cool to see his his beliefs applied on a
small scale first I think it would gain
trust I think people would believe in
him more and then he can do even more on
when he runs again I'm so in the moment
right now I don't know if there's going
to be another presidential election and
that's not even a joke so like I really
want the best right now and he I agree
with you that the Trust In VI is it's vi
just in case vi
vi vi uh he he came he came in like an
outsider and like okay what's his
politics stuff and you could see him
talking and like not really sure exactly
like what how much should I say right
away let's go and then as time went on I
think he became kind of a representative
of what the people wanted from him and
he started speaking massive truth to
power and people were like whoa is this
fake no it's he's doing what people want
to do Christy line where he's like you
sound like chat gbt when you talk did
you see that line I was actually I don't
I'm not a huge chrisy fan I thought it
was kind of funny but it's just it's
it's thec gbt yeah the sounds nothing
like J gbt right it's it was a it was
Chris Christie is just such a pathetic
failure of a man Donald Trump more like
Donald Duck and then he smirks like bro
that didn't land and he's smiling like
got him well they skipped there was like
a whole section of that debate where
they just skipped him he was so amazing
Donald Duck if Trump keeps duck in the
issues they're going to call him Donald
Duck ah D my mouth a little bit yeah I'm
I'm sold because of his Economic Policy
VI it's uh it's getting out us away from
Black Rock cuz I I don't even I'm not
even concerned about the Left Right
Paradigm the Republican Democrats any of
that I'm concerned with Global Banks
trying to take over and fasiz this
country um it's been happening for 100
years and they I mean you know that the
what was it called the banker plot or
the the business plot they actually
Sydney uh or what's that that general's
name um that they tried to get to
overthrow the butler Smedley Butler
these these businessmen went to
according to Smedley himself he he blew
the whistle on it uh they came to him
and tried to get him to to Stage a coup
on uh FDR in like 1933 or something uh
these businessmen this fascist takeover
and Smedley was like no I I love the
America I love the First Amendment and
I'm not going to do that and uh so those
people those people that Etho still
exists in this country and they've been
just doing it slowly incrementally they
got us off the gold standard you know
they got the Jackal Island they got the
Federal Reserve set up I I don't Jackal
Island yeah we got to get away from
these Bankers this Bankers Union thing
and and create a more reputable country
for the people something with like local
trade they don't want there to be
country
they want there to be
world yeah I'm I'm open to that but it's
got to happen judiciously I'm just going
to start referring to they as The
Enclave you know because what they'll
try to do is when when VI says they
won't let you do it they're like aha
he's an anti-em no I'm not talking about
Jewish people when I'm say when we say
they we're talking about the the the
intelligence agencies the wealthy
corporate Elites I mean should have call
it the UN I feel like if there was a
cultural if there is a cultural War
which there seems to be a cultural that
if we win if the American ethos wins
that people all over Earth will
overthrow their tyrannical governments
and create First Amendment rights and
gun rights and they'll take control of
their societies guys I I I've got bad
news for you okay you know we can sit
here talk about the importance of
Journalism and fear about what's to come
in 2024 but the prophet of Doom a
psychic has predicted cyber attacks
natural disasters and a Russia China
Alliance well the Propet of Doom says so
I mean look at this guy he knows so uh
that's it that's it boys pack it in uh
you may as well just uh flee to El
Salvador while you still can because uh
we're here who is this prophet of Doom
he claims to see into the future and he
says that uh you know there's going to
be he's got some serious predictions big
floods will engulf London in Europe a
new pandemic in Australia and President
Vladimir Putin will trip off this Mortal
coil coffee with Craig that's the you
know what's really funny is like we're
kind of we're kind of making fun of this
dude and everything but what all this
stuff actually came true well the global
uh Cyber attack that doesn't actually
feel like very specific of a prediction
for me it's like being like there will
be an election next year like get we
know all sorts of countries will have
elections next year I I wish they would
have some more specific details the
flood in London is kind of a bold choice
I think right that is a bold choice I
think the best way to go about this
would be to claim that a man from the
future gave you uh uh access to
information about what was going to
happen and uh that's what is is going to
happen unless because telling you
changes history it doesn't happen but
then it's not my fault it's your fault
actually it is interesting that is a
nice caveat to always be like but well
because I tried to save you you know now
now everything's going to be different I
can't really yeah that was uh do you
guys remember John
terer the it was a a meme thing in like
the 2000s a guy online posting on forums
claiming to be from the future and
showing pictures of like light bending
in a time machine and I think he was
saying that by 2008 the US would be
fractured into four different countries
stuff but of course he was like however
that may not happen because I've altered
the timeline oh there were some really
interesting and very intelligent things
that he said that made people is he the
one who said he like he traveled through
time to like three specific points in
time he came back multiple times to warn
people about things look at this he's
got a he's got a look at this John terer
John Teter and time travel zero
pseudonyms used on internet forums
between 2 2001 by an individual claiming
to be an American military time travel
from 2036 so so you're saying that in 13
years we got time travel their post
discussed various aspects of time travel
and described future calamitous events
including a global nuclear war the
uniform inaccuracy of their predictions
and inconsistencies in their
explanations has led many to view the
story with skepticism wait that was it I
kind of think if a guy goes online and
says I'm from the future that instantly
disqualifies it from being true but okay
like maybe there's a 0.000000 1% Chance
some time traveler is telling the truth
it was a hoax created by Larry Haber a
Florida entertainment lawyer and his
brother John Rick Haber a computer
scientist the claims have never been
verified however interesting okay I I
think they know it was a hoax I've read
a lot about doomsayers throughout the
history of humanity and it's actually
more common than I think people realize
it's so easy to say that the worst thing
is going to happen and to make the
claims about all the the risks and how
they're all going to fail and that's
going to cause the end and the failure
but I think it's way more likely that
things are going to march on it's just a
matter of staying still surviving
community and I'm with you on that I
think I I'm I'm more of an optimist I I
think what a time to be alive what a
time to make a difference right now and
and and the truth is so powerful I know
it's very corny and cliche and people
are probably going to laugh at this but
you you you have a dark room just a
little little flame it lights up the
room the truth has that power it just
does and I think it'll ultimately win as
long as people are courageous enough to
say to say it and his and and
historically in like the Soviet Union
these other countries they couldn't say
it they had to live by lies they had to
they had to pretend they even though
they knew the truth they didn't want to
say it and as long as we have the
courage to say it in numbers I think
we'll be okay and also the ability to
preserve it which I think storing data
in orbit like we really need to get away
from these centralized servers or at
least expand in a decentralized storage
the truth can be unfortunately on the
internet tweaked in real time the truth
I call it that's true I mean we we talk
about this all the time people like
Netflix will take uh scenes out of shows
if they decide they're unpopular or
incorrect it's weird that we edit the
content that we have it's like you're
unable to preserve an original document
which is crazy it's it's terrifying do
you have any white pill predictions for
uh 2024 anything particular you think
positive white pill I like that question
that's a good premise um as I said I
think the last couple weeks of 2023 if
or any precursor I think you're going to
see whatever the if there's corruption
or fraud
occurring like if there's a conspiracy
somewhere I think that conspiracy will
be made public for us to see now we
could argue whether that's going to make
a difference that's a different
conversation so if there's if there's
voter fraud and I don't know if there's
going to be enough of it but if there is
I think we'll see it in 2024 yeah in
other words we'll be able to see the
fraud happening on the inside the
whistleblowers will come public they'll
reveal it on video in controvertible and
and now whether that now whether that's
going to be um uh shocking enough to
people who who like for example hate
orange man you know bad very bad then
then I don't know but I think we'll be
able to see it in a way that we've never
seen it before and we're seeing it right
it's like we're going to see it in a way
we've never seen it before I've never
seen anything like it are you familiar
with the apocalypse from the Bible like
it's it's a Biblical prophecy entering
like the they call it the end times who
knows what that actually means if the
calendar is just resetting or something
but it it basically means apocal me the
great revealment the things are being
revealed and so what do you think about
things like neural net where people are
plugging in machines and our we can
share our thoughts I don't know anything
about that well it's just the elon's way
of making brain computer interface a
little better than using fingers you can
use your thoughts to communicate on the
machine now I feel like norl net would
be the worst thing for whistleblowers
right like if the government or whoever
was plugged into your brain you started
thinking maybe I want to say something
about what's going on wherever I well
there were reports today Ashley s Clair
reported that the American Airlines one
of the airlines was forcing people to
download something onto their phone the
pilot to track whether they're talking
to James o ke or not and I just tweeted
out just go to Walmart and buy another
phone M and just download signal but
there are efforts like this and but even
that you know in in these other
countries no descent was per
historically no descent was permitted at
all you know you and and and now you're
seeing the the the opposite effect like
it's almost you know you know Orwell
feared the truth would be concealed from
us Huxley feared the truth would be
drowned out in a sea of irrelevance so
the question Tim's point I I think was
on point which is that our audience have
become so segmented how do you convince
the people that don't agree with you
don't just play to your audience play to
the people who don't agree and and and
to the white pill question I think I
believe still believe that if you if you
if you expose the truth in such a way
it'll convince the people that don't
agree with me like for example the story
on fiser or black rock or um or or even
voter fraud the problem with the voter
fraud I've heard from the writing is
that I don't think anyone's ever
actually proved it I think it's all
circumstantial evidence I mean can you
name a a case where we've really
actually proved incontrovertible
evidence of massive voting fraud I
haven't seen that I haven't seen massive
that's I guess enough swing an election
I I personally Haven I mean there's
different ways that they coers you know
propaganda the media but you know what
I'm saying I I think that there's going
to be people on the inside in 2024
recording this stuff and there's nothing
they can do to stop it hypoth
would you would you support like a
technology that just blows everyone's
Minds open so that we can read every
human's brain I didn't I had even
thought about the implications of that I
I would you would you support that why
because we're going to destroy ourselves
if we don't you people have the right to
the privacy of their own thoughts well
no not anymore I
feel look what people did with that they
secrecy and destruction and slave slavit
toe that they've done to humans it's hor
horrific I don't like a world where I'm
obligated to let anyone read my mind
that sounds I just think that they
thought that it's your mind is like kind
of out of like our thoughts are not our
own it's our mind it is our mind it's
the global mind I mean obiously we have
autonomies as bodies My Little Pony it's
our little well not really if it's not
my mind it's not my body right I mean
what where do you draw this line um also
like to my point before that would
completely blow up a whistleblower
system right if if your thoughts were
public to everyone we would never have
anyone come forth because theoretically
they would immediately be imprisoned if
they even thought about saying hey I
should report this to someone the
corruption would never happen because if
someone tried to ruin the system
managing this the corrup the species the
entire species would be like policing
itself at all times kind of whoever's on
the top of that structure would be
policing it I don't think there is a top
if it's all connected I so I don't think
it's a good thing but I think Ian
presents a possible future that we've
actually talked about on the culture War
the way I describe it is with AI with
with nurlink and all this stuff what
eventually happens is humans will be
treated like cell like single cells in a
multicellular organism so uh take a look
at single cells right they're all
running around doing crazy whozits and
whatnots they're eating stuff and making
more of themselves and they're
independent in and of themselves
multicellular organisms all the cells
have clearly defined roles and within
the multicellular organism like each and
every one of us here sometimes there are
rogue actors they want to be free they
want to be free and they want to do
whatever they want to do and what do we
call that cancer yes diseas and what do
we do to canc pathogens usually we
consume them with white blood cells we
destroy them and so in a future where
we're all neuralink and we're all being
given our roles and to each according to
their need and you know from each
according to their capabilities what
ends up happening then is this nightmare
dystopia where you rip the neuralink out
of your neck and you're like I just want
to be me and then you're hunted down by
law enforcement who are all AI link
mindless drones and then they destroy
you liquefy your body and convert you
into resource I don't think You' ever
want to want to disengage from the
species cancer ex I mean that's true and
maybe what I'm saying is I'm looking at
stripping Humanity of joy and pain and
love and hate and all these things that
make it so wonderful but awful to be a
human but at the same time man those
kids pulling Cobalt out of the minds in
Africa where people are just like no no
no let's not look at that like come on
man it's like how many thousands of kids
are getting poisoned right now CLA at
that stuff for us to get our cell phones
and and yes and now do you weep for the
the the skin cells that die and are
flect off your body in an AI neural net
world when your brain is plugged into
the machine you'll know all about it and
you will you will not care it the the
people who are mining the Cobalt won't
care either they'll just be the dead
cells flaking off into the wind but I
feel like we would be working out of our
way to make sure humans don't have to
suffer through that stuff if we were all
one unit if your brain is linked to a a
a neural net where everyone is like one
Hive they wouldn't be suffering there
would no longer be a you they would be
mindless
drones I don't know if it'd be mindless
they'd be mindless I don't think we have
to worry about this prior to November 24
correct I think you're right I think I
think let's take it let's take it one
year at a time because there's a lot lot
going on you want to answer these big
philosophical questions I mean it's a
fascinating it's a fascinating Pandora's
box but to get back to to this coming 20
this is the last show of the year right
Tim this is the last show so so a truly
free press empowers people to make
decisions for themselves and that's what
this is this movement is all about I
mean you have the the the the Press is
is putting things in simplifications and
stereotypes and obfuscation and and all
types of carefully woven tapestry of
words that obfuscate and then you just
have Elon musk's X and whistleblowers
and this is all about empowering people
to make decisions because they have
access to information they previously
did not and it's the lack of
transparency in the world that is the
advantage to the to the evil so the
theory the the white pill is by making
the world more transparent than it's
ever been not mind I don't even
know about that that's a metaphysical
thing that I have I have to really I
have to sleep on that but let's just
take it to the next level just having
access to inside of Airlines inside of
the DHS inside the IRS inside the FBI if
those walls could talk imagine if the
American people could see that and hear
that for themselves imagine that I
actually think that the the whatever the
outcome would be would be the correct
one but right now people have no idea
what's happening and and we're debating
facts what it's the the the greatest
tragedy of modern society is we debate
facts why are we debating facts we
shouldn't be but we've made so many
things subjective right they have
decided they shouldn't be but there is a
whole whole bent of like I mean bring it
up every show but the gender stuff right
saying well gender is different than sex
and this is why you can feel this way
but actually this is that that's one
thing I think that they they there's
there's a economic incentive to focus on
these kind of issues that divide people
but so wouldn't that be true for
anything that is a fact that people try
to manipulate probably have an in
corruptive coercive power of the federal
government the weaponization of the
federal government innocent Americans I
think these are winning issues and the
majority of people I also think chopping
off private parts off little boy that's
a winning issue 90% of people think
that's wrong I think if people could see
and hear the stench the rot for
themselves that's why I'm a white pilled
guy because I know it's going to happen
it's already happening and you have
people who come from inside and come out
and tell you hey I want to talk about
this because I think it's wrong that
must be a very uplifting
it's it's it's a a heavy experience it's
it's heavy uh I and and and I actually
Tim you know one of the things I I I've
learned is you know we were talking
about this off off off air is that it's
hard for um yeah I got to be careful who
I surround myself with oh yeah you know
after what I've been through and and
I've got all these people contacting me
I got to make sure people on my team
close to me I can trust them are people
are people
possessed by parasites yeah uh I believe
so it it look the stuff I've learned
about your Story the stuff I've
experienced it feels like one day a
demon enters their brain and takes them
over Dude I think they're literal
parasites in your gut I'm about to do
some combo it's this toad Venom and
apparently you puke up parasites and
they just come out Luke rowski has a we
are change video from seven years ago I
think there's much simpler ways the
combo stuff is about like experiencing
death or something yeah but also a purge
it's a purge of this controlling
for Christmas Ian no I don't know ho ho
ho baby yeah take me there no short
after
what I've learned is my fight and many
fights like this it's almost like a
fight against human nature it's almost
like a fight against self-interest for
goodness or for truth or for you know
not betraying your conscience and
there's a lot of people out there who
are the world is governed by people
pursuing their own self-interest so if
you're going to run against that tide
you better make sure the people who are
around you share those values or your
partner shares your values if you're
going to be on a Mission Against
self-interest and I think that's what
it's going to take you mentioned the
founding fathers get was their lives
Fortune sacred honor blood treasure and
sacred honor blood treasure and they did
that for them for each other they they
they were risking their children their
children these are guys who were wealthy
had families and they could have said
look if we remain loyalists the king
will take care of us and we let everyone
else burn instead they said I will stand
with the people of my community even
though they had land landed gentry and
they told the king to screw off they
felt their children were at risk either
way right one what future will I leave
for my children yeah Ben Franklin lost
his kid he his son William refused to
ever speak to him again because he he
his son was a loyalist he wouldn't leave
the a experence like I got to do what's
right my own son I think we all know
people whose whose families don't speak
to each other because of politics right
I know people who are like if you voted
for Trump I'll never speak to I'll never
speak to you again right they like this
is something we still experience today
but if you believe that your country is
at risk if you believe the future of the
people you love could be damaged by an
outcome don't you feel more obl morally
obligated to act William Franklin was
imprisoned by Patriots from 76 to 78 and
he was the chief leader of the loyalists
in New York City organizing military
units to fight back on the side of the
British he went to Exile in Britain and
lived in London until his death I never
saw him again crazy that's a wild
sacrifice sometimes the doing the right
thing and the hard thing are the same
thing I'm looking at a tip right now I
can't tell you what it is or who it is
or it is but it's big and I I get these
every 10 minutes quote I don't know if
this is Major new J major News James but
I thought I would just do the right
thing and it reminds me of a quote by um
the big tobacco whistle Jeffrey W Gan
1990s asked by Mike Wallace why you
doing this gave up everything he goes he
goes because it's right he said because
it's right so there are very we could
all agree that that's a very tiny
fraction of humans who would who would
do that and say that therefore Tim my
fight is a fight against uh human nature
in many regards and you said demonically
possessed when you're fighting against
when you're fighting against and we all
have demons right every single one of us
unless you're a liar we all have things
that we're ashamed of perhaps that we've
done but if you're fighting for good
what's going to happen when you're
fighting for good you're going to be
faced with Tim you're going to be faced
with with bad people doing bad things
and saying bad things and demons you
could say when you say right and wrong I
feel that's should always be up for
debate because like transparency for the
sake of transparency I'm not into
anymore I i' I've considered it
throughout life but like National
Defense weapons programs like the
Manhattan Project we could not if people
had blown the whistle on that and given
the the specs to oh we talked about this
a turning point if if they' revealed
open source the data for the nuclear
bomb and Hitler got it and built it
first we'd all be speaking ger hang on
you the guy who just pitched that all of
our thought should be public is are
noted to transparency for transparency
say if you could flip a switch Maybe but
uh maybe but uh yeah yeah there's some
things that where you need I'm not
that's a good point thank you but the
journalist is there's a book written
about this called the custodians of
conscience the custodians of conscience
you you you you you the information
revealer forms the moral values by
releasing the information and testing
and affirming what is and what is not
moral you you realize that by going oh I
called my OMG oh my God like when the
fiser guy is saying we make fake things
to lie to customers to make money or
Black Rock saying we control the world
we bribe politicians okay that's wrong
and that's that's the kind of role of
transparency is it not to to test and
affirm what is and what is not moral by
revealing information that shocks the
conscience you're the custodian of the
Public's conscience they're going to
like Quantum encryption hacking is a big
technology like 2028 we're going to
start seeing people be able to go into
and like open up the last 20 years of
your bank records like everyone on Earth
they're Bank like and and so is that
conscionable to do is is it cons do it
just to some and not to others but do
people need to know that it's happening
is the question right do people know
that that's occurring or should they
know that that that's occurring I think
so but
sometimes yes in that instance yes
sometimes I don't sometimes there are
things that are happening that if people
know they panic and
and that could do more harm than keeping
them in the dark then that's the balance
that you have to strike as the publisher
of the information do some things should
not be some things ought to be kept
secret but I think you you you derive
your sense of morality through the
reporting process and the public changes
their sense of of what is right and
wrong based upon whether it whether it
tugs at their conscience the word is
conscience I would say you know you know
what people uh don't remember is the de
aration of dependence what tell me about
it uh it's always sunny in in
Philadelphia made the joke where they
envisioned back in the olden days during
the Revolutionary period and uh Mack and
Dennis are scared that the rebellion in
Philadelphia will result in them losing
their bar or whatever so they're like we
need to tell the British that we support
them and so they bring the Declaration
of Independence but it's actually just a
crude drawing of someone raping the king
the queen or something like that but uh
there actually was a loyalist
declaration and I'm trying to be careful
because I don't know too much about it
but I have this from the New York
Historical Society Museum library it was
the loyalist petition to the crown that
some people refer to as the Declaration
of of dependence where the Loyalists
said they had risked their their lives
and fortunes opposing the most unnatural
unprovoked Rebellion that ever disgraced
the anal of time the Loyalists sought
some level of Distinction from the
inhabitants in general they were asking
the crown to uh alleviate them of the
martial law as they were loyalists the
funny thing is the crown ignored
them there you go it is what it is so
they appealed to to the authority and
what does that show that that Authority
was evil because it ignored their pleas
well it's funny because the uh uh the
Patriots were like the the the king is
an oppressive force and then the
loyalists were like King we're on your
side help us and he was an oppressive
force on them too so yeah get what you
get but you know I bring this up because
we don't sit here and talk about the men
who risked their fortunes to serve the
crown no one cares about those guys the
British people care about them yeah they
don't
like when I was talking to Carl Benjamin
I was like do you guys like what what's
what's the the thought on in in Britain
on the American Revolution he's like
mate our history is like what is it like
12200 years like this was this was like
a small 20-year period in a thousand
year history BP on our radar it's like
it happened but we had a lot of colonies
we learned about all the colonies we had
not just you he didn't say it exactly
like that but he was basically saying it
I like the Indian Revolution uh that
Gandhi LED cuz that was nonviolent
essentially I don't know too much about
it actually I'd love to learn more about
it well I got to say the colonization of
of India is I think perhaps one of the
greatest things that has ever happened
um because it resulted in uh chicken
tick Masala and butter chicken of course
which were invented in London but
nonetheless inspired by India kumin I
guess
tum delicious coriander uh all right
let's go apparently yoga was like a
military training exercise back in the
day I didn't a religious spiritual thing
but it came from actual that's why they
call it like Warrior one like there's
actual it was they wouldn't let women do
it and it was just for warrior training
like for military training stretching
all these things to get ready for battle
you know I love in the UK Yorkie bars
mhm not for girls what is that the
Yorkie is a chocolate bar and it says
not for girls and there's a picture of a
girl and it's Circle the line through it
no girls can't have it I don't think
they could do that in the United States
I think it'd be illegal anyway we're go
to Super Chat so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel my friends
this is it the final show of 2023 cuzz
after this it's Christmas I hope you all
have a Merry Christmas this is this is a
a Christmas travel weekend it's going to
be a nightmare for everybody and then uh
we're off for the rest of the week you
know basically the way it works
especially with Christmas falling on
it's on Monday right I guess it is it is
a Monday literally impossible to do
shows nothing we can do about it so like
there were I think the first year we
were like no no we'll do we'll like
obviously Christmas off but we'll try
and get people nobody nobody will come
nobody I mean come on what sane person
is like yes I'd like to travel after
Christmas from my family's house
straight to your studio to do a show and
then have New Year's in a different city
it just doesn't happen I would love to
go through the airport at that time of
year yeah exactly nobody wants to do it
spend some time with your friends and if
you have friends that don't have a place
to go invite them over yeah New Year's
this will be fun let's read some super
chats all right Shane H Wilder says
merry Christmas everybody hope it's a
joyful one Jackson glass with not a
single word but won the first Super Chat
congratulations sir nice job Jackson oh
I want to let you guys know something
too for everybody who bought the song um
uh uh together again the first week is
is over this is launch week we're now I
I I don't know if the Billboard charts
come out Tuesday or next week the week
after Tuesday which would be January 2nd
not sure but we are going to email every
single person that b the song with a
promo code for 35% off cast Brew because
some people were unsure how to do it and
how to use it and then we're going to
extend just for one we really do want
you to buy the coffee so it's like it's
a promo for us but just to make sure
there were a lot of people emailed in
saying I'm not quite sure how to get it
don't worry about it we're going to send
everybody an email you'll get your code
and you can buy all the coffee at a huge
discount thank you so much for
supporting us and buying the song This
was the biggest release we have done yet
it was more sales more views more
everything um I owe a lot of that to the
Daily wire crew Jeremy boring and
Michael nolles also helped push
considering they have the writing credit
on it it's like the lyrics were all
theirs it was inspired by their song
though we'd made a different version of
it they're absolutely a part of helping
promote it so shout out to the Daily
wire
crew all right n dierence says James X
dancer here giving you moonwalk
props I can moonwalk I can break dance I
can sing Oklahoma and I'm coming back to
Tim's Studio to produce some music great
story I also I do I do dance parties I I
went to the amfest trying to sell
journalism classes and I sold out my
class but thousand people asked me
where's my next James O'Keefe party so
we may need to have those regular every
month we're going to sell the tickets
it'll be the greatest thing you've ever
seen have you seen O'Keefe dance okay
it's like you wouldn't believe okay
you've got three weeks you need to set
up a party in Iowa Iowa caucus yeah that
would be so party in I actually that's
not a bad idea January 15th caucus
everyone's going to be there we're
actually January 15th we're working out
the details for IRL live it's it's all
preliminary my chief of staff is going
to hate me sending a I mean look look we
get hit up and we're like would you guys
wanted like hey I got an idea for you du
IRL from the Iowa caucus and we're like
that is a good idea we've got the Iowa
caucus is what day the 15th 15th a
O'Keefe Iowa caucus dance party best
best thing ever and now but hold on and
and super Tuesday March 5th James
O'Keefe super Tuesday super party super
Tuesday where what state oh you got to
pick one March because you got super
Tuesday it's to so many different states
we'll figure it out Texas is Texas super
Tuesday I'm checking dude you guys put
on a Slayer after show at amfest I got
invited out but we were already no I was
we got a jet back so I missed you miss
you missed you missed an unbelievable
party it's I don't know what happened I
guess it's just the O'Keefe parties are
lit let's go to Patriot Punk Network
says I am the Patriot punk from the
Patriot Punk Network James is my hero we
just released a new expose on a corrupt
sheriff in Tennessee please give a shout
out to PCS OE I'm sorry PCS oh exposed
to help us fight corruption shout out
shout out go Texas isn't super Tuesday
but it's Alabama Alaska Arkansas
California Colorado Iowa Maine
Massachusetts Minnesota North Carolina
Oklahoma Tennessee oh no Texas is on
here uh Utah Vermont Virginia maybe
Texas Texas Tennessee n Nashville I mean
Nashville is where it's at Nashville
super
Tuesday shows up just dominates the
dance floor but what's really funny is
everyone always makes fun of the dancing
and he lives in Florida sorry everyone's
always like oh the theater and then they
secretly like DM like hey hey can can
can I get can I get a ticket to the
party though every time every time every
time every time they rag on it your
secret is safe with me okay I protect my
sources they rag on it and then they go
James James moonwalk moonwalk James it's
like that scene with with the the where
they throwing rocks at Michael J fox
he's doing the moonwalk they love when
they do the moonwalk yeah Michael
Jackson all right Jay Marie says James
O'Keefe has huge what is this
weos quos sorry oh they spelled it w v I
know what they meant it's the J because
I'm like you guys need to grow a pair of
balls and then the but I'm a woman I
don't have balls so I'm like all right
quos
have testicular fortitude fertilize your
eggs wellos is eggs so that works for
the ladies eggs balls it's a metaphor
but no I'm saying that works for the
ladies cuz L does that's why that's I
think they they may have been
referencing something I've said in
various I was just making I was just
poking fun for spelling it w v o oh they
spelled it like that that's weird it's j
I believe it's j u v o yeah it's hos H
it's h yeah hos quos yeah hos see I
don't even know how to spell
it what do we got here we are um Mr Wise
Guy play says will you read this the
answer is yes I play games and share my
opinions it's only a hobby for now it's
called Mr Wise Guy three channels it's
wh Wiz interesting good luck good
sir beep beep says James are you still
looking for an EA or has that role been
filled no I I I has not been filled and
part of the challenge I'm going do
extreme vetting okay I had 200 resumés
um still open you can apply at o'keef
Med my emails James o'keef mediagroup
do.com please send me a cover letter uh
it has to be specific about why you want
to work there and resume James at o'keef
medg group.com if you want to be the EA
positions in New Jersey right now and
and you have to be willing to travel all
the time do you sing James I do are
there are there any songs you like top
40s you know off the top of your head
top 40 right now I don't even off the
top I head know what's on the top 40 but
you know I just mean like big songs that
something that Ian might know how to
play um I know this is tough cuz like I
mean how about how about that song by um
Miley Cyrus flowers I don't think Ian
knows how to play flowers I can look up
the chords of any song pretty much you
name if I know it I can that has three
cords bet while while they're looking
this up gamer wenus says infringed was
great worth the watch thanks for all
your hard work Merry Christmas it was it
was super good super good and um maybe
what we'll do is now that it's like it's
it's had its run basically we did the
promo we can release it on uh the
timcast channel for like a couple bucks
like so you go on YouTube and they have
this thing where it's like you can pay a
couple bucks and it'll play for you I
think that yeah that'd be pretty cool we
could probably just do that that way
it's like you know it goes from the
movie theaters to then the video store
and then you know whatever that'll be
what we'll do
and so we could do the same with game of
money and put them up on YouTube for
like $1.99 or something that's a great
idea yeah and people can watch them
that'd be very cool yeah yeah was to
we're working on more we got more more
awesome stuff to come Andrew H says
everyone forgets the great predictor
movie Die Hard 4 that educated us on the
fire sale Cyber attack to wipe out the
power grid drain Social Security
monetary resources Etc it was good yep I
like that movie don't people think die
one of the die hards is a Christmas
movie the first one the first one cuz it
happens during Christmas oh okay right
I've seen it so I the it's a semantic
argument what is a Christmas movie is a
Christmas movie a movie about someone
going through the process of Christmas
and Santa comes and then they have
presents or is a Christmas movie a movie
that is set at Christmas time right or
or involving Christmas as a component of
the story interesting I think it's if
it's about Christmas because if you like
played a rock song in the country it
wouldn't be a country song just cuz it's
in the country but that's not what we're
saying right is is Jurassic Park a
dinosaur movie yes of course it's about
dinosaurs right but what if there was um
is is Godzilla a dinosaur movie uh
technically I guess maybe this is this
is where people like well yeah like
Godzilla's basically a dinosaur a
gigantic monster lizard you know
rampaging if you made a movie about a
giant monster like a giant T-rex
rampaging through city streets would you
call it a dinosaur movie and it's like
well it's not it's it's a dinosaur is in
it but it's like part of the story
dinosaur movie that's a good point but
this is this is what the argument is Die
Hard happens during Christmas and
Christmas is a theme it's a Christmas
party and then they make Christmas
references but it's not a movie about
delivering presents to your family is is
home alone a Christmas movie I always
think it is yeah I think so than die
hard is because home alone is a movie by
a kid who gets left at home the
Christmas element of it is is
meaningless it and that was during
Christmas too and they leave him because
of Christmas they're traveling as a
family out so it's affects the plot so
it's a Christmas christm
but at what point the mie is it like you
got race to get the presents and then
there is where he meets Santa and
everything I get that yeah and Donald
Trump makes an appearance in one of
those movies right second one second one
lost in New York was that a Christmas
movie yeah cuz it happens they all
happen at Christmas right so then Die
Hard is too yeah oh right
interesting yeah it's like the kid all
the kid does is is mercilessly M and
wound two burglars you know what I mean
it's CRI movie that's very but hold on
hold on Daniel Stern Merry Christmas and
Home Alone are like almost the same
movie never saw Merry Christmas what is
what is what is uh
um what's Die Hard guy's name wow I
can't believe forgot the actor or no no
the
character John mlan mlan yeah we got
what is he doing he's sneaking around
playing pranks on these terrorists right
it's a bit more direct but the
terrorists like walk in the room and
like the walkie-talkie goes off and they
come in and then beats the crap out of
him and then he's got the Gun tape to
his back it's the same story you know
kind of die Harden Home Alone James
doesn't agree that die heart a Christmas
movie he's got his shirt off and he's
got a a gun duct tape to his back and
then he's like yipp K and he grabs it
just just like Santa just like when the
paint can falls down and hits Murray in
the face love that scene when he steps
on the broken glass you guys remember
when Family Guys spoofed home alone oh
they like walk in the house and the one
guy's like a paint can swings down yeah
oh that was weird and he's like yeah
there was some glue on the porch but I
just walked over it yeah the door knob
was hot I just let go and then the kid
Kevin Macer goes Haha I've got you now
and he goes bang and just shoots them
and he's like all right you want to
steal stuff
yeah home they're like now home alone
with competent burglar it's great they
like no Witnesses or whatever so funny
it's so
good where we at let's grab uh what what
is this is this Dom says Rothchild LLC
bought a large amount of Boeing shares
today Black Rock Street and others
boosted their existing Boeing Holdings
as well they're gearing up for World War
III maybe but the implication is if
they're buying stock they don't intend
the world to fail they think at some
point someone will want to buy those
stocks as well so yeah you know that's
the thing when people start buying up
water like if if I don't know like Mark
Zuckerberg was going to spend $250
million on say like a Hawaiian emergency
underground bunker with like massive
private security then I'd be worried
right oh wait he did
that anyway now to be fair Zuckerberg
bought a massive mansion on uh the one
one of the western most islands of
Hawaii and it includes a 5,000 foot
bunker the media makes it seem more like
he's building a quarter billion dollar
emergency bunker in the middle of
nowhere to be fair however most of the
ultra wealthy are doing that so you know
as soon as they start flying to New
Zealand or to Montana to their Mountain
bunkers yeah I think a bunch of them
have Deep Mountain bunkers in like
Wyoming and Montana watch what they do
not what they say exactly they're like
everything is fine the stocks are great
and they're they're doing a live feed as
they're lowering into like a submarine
going to their underwater under exactly
well you know uh rumor is the ultra
wealthy have built a city underwater I
thought it was under the Denver Airport
no no no they built it underwater Oh
where they can be free from regulation
yeah they call it Rapture uh I want to
go there
we make every every single day on this
show we make Bioshock references every
every day in the chat there's a poll
would you kindly share and like the show
yeah would you kindly wow I don't know
what Bioshock is one of the best video
games ever made firstperson shooter RPG
it's awesome adding down to my cult it's
uh it's underwat sci-fi fantasy based
off of like objectivist ideas from like
the Fountain Head and um Atlas sh that's
cool the B the boss is actually is
literally named Atlas
and uh the story is basically ultra
wealthy people build a city underwater
to escape regulation and uh a core
component of the story is that gene
splicing becomes rampant because there's
no regulations and people are injecting
themselves with genetic modification
that gives them powers and so in the
first one I love it in the original
Bioshock because you you'll get like
you'll get uh I forgot what they're
called um it's been so long since I
played it but he it actually shows the
arms and then it goes like and sticks
the needle in the arm and then fire
comes out of his hand but then when when
they did BioShock Infinite he's drinking
a soda that's how he gets it is he
drinks it yeah in BioShock Infinite I
think they were like the injecting into
the arm is not very
family he cracks a soda and drinks it
and that it's like ah come on but then
some people end up becoming deranged
from splicing and so they're like and
they're all messed up regulation and all
bad that's true what do we got Gabriel
Lopez as a country is not an idea of a
piece of paper they are a people if you
switch the entire population of us and
Brazil the Constitution would be taken
down overnight and everything would be
would Brazil immigration legal or
illegal will kill Americans it's over a
n a country is its people that's right
did you figure out how to play Miley
Cyrus I I have the chords I just don't
know could sing something more simple
like ohow it a beautiful morning I don't
know is that too old school I like it
it's very simple it's very this is this
is your big break James you better not
screw it up Friday night jam session
with James o' this is like 1939 right
now about House of the Rising Sun House
of the Rising Sun that one's easy what
are the chords for that a what is that a
CDF I'm a base 2 so it's got to be low
octave W there's a lot of chords in o a
beautiful
morning there is a house but House of
the Rising Sun you know the I'm not
going to be able to play that one how's
the Rising Sun how I can play that one
yeah four chords I think I got to tune
this it should yeah it might have
slipped there is a house new was it a
minor
CDF the r a minor CDF there is yeah uh
it
is a minor CDF then it goes a minor
minor E A minor e yep that's probably
the chorus or something no that is just
like the last part of the uh and God I
know I'm one that's the a minor E A
minor okay A minor E A minor e yeah it's
rock or is it E A minor E A minor I
think you got a pick over there or
anything of course nice you can prepared
homie what room is this I should have
one on me thanks
we are going to close out this year with
a very short very simple Friday night
jam session James O'Keefe brings you
House of the Rising Sun I knew the first
part of the song is it just the repeat
of the first part same thing this great
you got the you want to pull the lyrics
and I got the
lyrics
the can you hear that
[Music]
okay
so I'll just do that again we go no no
you're you didn't play it right that's
what they says here there is there is
hold on a house down in New
[Music]
Orleans they
call little bit R and S give yourself
double the room so we can get the reverb
when you're singing it and it's
been the
ruin of many a poor
boy
and
God I
know I'm one same thing
right yeah oh my gosh Tim's joining in
on guitar a while since I've heard this
song are we allowed to play it on the
show is it the mother yeah
mother
was a
Tor she so
my
Dre my father the
was a Gambling
Man Down we
down keep it going
dud I don't know where am there this is
like a an inter we're going to be back
to the beginning or the only now the
only thing
ready now the only thing a Gambling Man
ever
KN is a suitcase Lord a suitcase and a
trunk and the only type of fool like him
is
satisfied is when is all Stone Cold
Stone Cold drunk back to the beginning
sure
ready almost
[Music]
almost oh let's just go right
into there is a house way down in New
Orleans they
call the rise and
sun and it's
been the ruin
of many a
t and God I know I'm not the
only
[Music]
one second verse no that's that one's it
did you already get the ball and chain
part I think that's that's good that's
that's that there we go that was what a
fun new band I've got an original I'd
like to play for you guys it's the first
song I ever wrote
yeah check this out I'm going to I'll
sing it up top I'll play it down here
first song I ever wrote It's called on
walking oh thanks Serge let's just do
this Serge is GNA throw me a microph I
think the single mic works as long as
it's right in between and you back up a
little yeah I can I can I can do it yeah
these are podcast mics so if you want to
sing into them you pull them back so
that you get the room you
[Music]
know
it's a little too low though what what
is to get your to get your voice
actually you're probably good you're
probably
good don't you pick me up on the road
again we're all just
friends
human be in there
alone
again
walking when I'm
tired take another picture from the
train
again let me
in through the window
pain for loving life from the stain I
madeen I spill the rain on your big
brain
I'm going to spin you around and put
your feet on the ground cuz you're
everything be great and be cliche and
the mistakes I've made will pay the
[Music]
way walking strong on the road
again make amend and move
[Music]
on and when I see you when I'm home
again I'll show you then I do
strong yeah when I see you around I'll
put my feet on the ground cuz we're
everything be shameful be naive K Cola
is your dream you're something
[Music]
strange You're Something
abnormally something
unpredictably
irresistible to me
something in a right
I got stuck got no luck got no key to
the door that I
locked pass it by or break it down it's
time to face the clown and I'll find a
way to
refrain that
stain is
[Music]
PL so
strange so strange
so
[Music]
strange that I made myself made myself
made myself made
myself pass it by or break it down it's
time to face the Clown I'll find a way
to a way to
refrain cuz I made my made myself made
myself made
myself all right James what else do you
know no you have to sing a Christmas
girl now Christmas you guys give me some
options and I'll sing give me some
different options Glycerine by Bush no
way you guys are not festive at all
that's my favorite song Come on come on
we want we the point is top 40s big hit
James sing a couple op All I Want For
Christmas Is You by Mariah I can sing
that one that's a good one that's
every come on let's do that you know how
to play we might be able Tock figure it
out I'm loving this optimism that's like
the most famous Christmas song of all
time yes let's do that one we can figure
this out
Christmas I mean it's not a complicated
song E minor c d yeah you can do it
everyone's talented I would have to
listen to the song listen to it for a
second get the key of
G oh yeah this is
it just listen to the first
[Music]
year C
minor this is a little complicated you
just got to get those chords I don't
we're not getting it Oh no you're not
going to do it we're not going to get it
it's too difficult it's not that it's
difficult it's that something like House
of the Rising Sun is four chords you're
done I see so if we're going to pull up
a random song right now and just play
without having heard it
easy to be like next year last the year
before Christmas I could play the iPad
way back here and you guys can kind of
strum along you want to try that here we
go here we go now
we cop yeah we can't can't do that okay
right even even with covers it's kind of
weird I appreciate the effort though
classic it's such a great song it is a
classic but pick a few option what is
there anybody who's got suggestions in
the chat cuz we're going to maybe
there's suggestions we're going to wrap
it up in a second it's not that
complicated but it's what copyright so
we don't no it's that like if we're
going to actually play it right I would
need to listen to the song figure out
what the chords are Christmas when when
you're signed to the label will come
back the whole Christmas album you can
rip the whole thing down to four chords
and ignore whatever the actual song is I
Like That C minor though Silent Night
Jingle Bells Baby It's Cold Outside Last
Christmas by wh last Christmas gave you
my can you do that wonder wall I can bir
wonder wonder wall what else you got
keep going what about
last Christmas is hot last Christmas can
we do that that's a lot of seven chords
let's
see
last can you do that
[Music]
one nope Hallelujah Tears for Fears
Tears for Fears which one oh how about
uh everybody wants to change the world
yeah that's a good one Everybody Wants
to Rule the World Everybody Wants to
Rule I think I know that song well
enough to may be able to I just
retweeted them playing it live they're
so good as long as you get the pitch
right welcome to
your to your life there's no turning
back even while can we get that let's
see yeah maybe it's a is that the right
key
welcome welcome to your life
there we
go there's just nothing really
there you want me to start yeah you want
to play it in then we go I think we got
[Music]
it I don't think so rock you can play
that lead like that I could play the
rhythm but
[Music]
that's da da here we go keep
going here we
go welcome to your
life there's no
turning
back even while we
sleep we will find you acting on your
best behavior turn your back on mother
nature
everybody wants to R the
world keep going keep
going it's my home
design it's my own
remorse yeah help me to
decide help me make the world stop it
down the lyrics stop I can't remember
the words
Everybody Wants to Rule the World here's
the bridge there's a room where the
light won't find you holding hands while
the walls keep tumbling down when they
do I'll be right behind you I'm so glad
we've almost made I'm so sad they had to
fade
everybody wants to do the work
oh just says on the a yeah they right on
the a oh I wish I had a bigger screen
there's one more little part here
ready I can't stand this indecision
stand this
indecision married live the lack of
vision
everybody wants to do the world say this
is this is the the chorus say that
you'll never never can't do that
part you want to keep going I that was
pretty good I think we got what we
needed out of it that was great what a
great song I can't I can't go higher I
can't stand this inis that's too high
for my vocal cord let's see got an
octave below there it's all about
getting would do it though I could
I don't want a lot for Christmas there
is just one thing I need and I don't
care about the present underneath the
Christmas tree AC capella I just want
you for my own more than you could ever
known make my wish come
true all I want for
Christmas is you that was amazing I
think Acappella that was incredible what
a Christmas gift to the audience marah
care is shaking in her boots right now
all right Tim what's your next one you
get wanted I don't got any ones you want
to play uh one of yours I don't know 90s
what's the one what's the next one the
next big one coming out in 2024 the next
song we're doing yeah what do you want
to do next I I I don't know so the song
that we're working on where Ian did the
body transformation it takes 48 hours to
render 10 seconds of the video because
it's all like heavy CGI and crazy
effects so that one might be done by mid
January but we've we've got I think we
might have two other songs that are done
that are just sitting there unreleased
cuz were like I don't but I think by
March we might have like a between eight
and 10 songs so I I don't know I've got
a new one I've just wrote I could play
or I could do come down by Bush which I
really like a lot do you know the words
to come down do I know the melody is the
question the words I can look
up well there's got to be something
simpler and better that everybody
knows love hate get it wrong come me
right back down the size sleep the day
Let It Fade who is there to take your
place no one knows never will mostly me
but mostly you we you say do you do when
it all comes
down that I want to come back down from
this
Cloud it's taking me all this time to
find out what I need surge hit it
yeah all right I'm going to play a song
Give it to me this is the last show of
the year and I I am I am not practiced
but I will try to play the song anyway
and because uh someone said play words
in a book so this is uh a song that
we've never recorded give me those
chords really quick
uh CA wait
wait
CBA
GE and uh that might be it let's see if
I can play it maybe I can right love
this
[Music]
song Remember
When
we used to Hope For
Peace villains weren only on TV
[Music]
screen the Market's made
up of broken hopes and
dreams to put you back into
[Music]
mediocrity takeing Lord takeing spite of
this
focus on the ways I guess you never
change that
day it's hard to believe that you mean
nothing to
me cuz you used to be
[Music]
everything remember
when we used to fight for peace
but Heroes were all on TV
[Music]
screen my heart is made
up of broken hopes and
dreams I'll take my place in this
story taking more take in spite of this
and focus on the ways of really wish you
change that
day it's hard to believe that you mean
nothing to
me cuz you used to be
[Music]
[Applause]
everything there were words in a
book about what we've been
through there are lives in a Str
written for me and you to take it all
inside and pray it
words another aching in your heart
starts to
[Music]
[Applause]
burn
takeing more take in spite of this and
focus on the ways I really hope you'll
change
someday it's hard to believe but I'm
moving on with my dreams
you were never there for
[Applause]
me then words in a
book about what we've been through and
there are light in a
script written for me and you to take it
all in stride and pray it
works another aing in your heart starts
to
[Music]
burn and that is the end of the year
what a year 2023 thank you James o for
for hanging out everybody uh go to
timcast become a member you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me at timcast James you want to shout
anything out it's going to be a wild
ride Tim and I'm going to come back and
make some music with
you definitely you anything else
I I wasn't even trying to pitch anything
O'Keefe Media Group OMG support us by
our journalism class sign up to be an
undercover journalist buy our cameras
and I'm going to make some music with
Tim and I have so many ideas right now
and that was a lot of fun that was the
highlight of my year thank you it's been
awesome having you here I'm Hannah Clair
brimo I'm a writer for SC r.com that's
scanner news I'm uh really thankful to
the entire team for all their work this
year and just always to uh to be a part
of them that group if you want to follow
their work you can follow timcast news
on Instagram and Twitter if you want to
follow me personally I'm on Twitter at
hcbo and I'm on Instagram at hanac clarb
guys Merry Christmas have a fun New Year
over to Ian thank you Hannah clir and
yeah is going to get loud in 2024
so let's make sure that we're the ones
in the noise that people are listening
to with our beautiful beautiful sound
Tim's got one more thing to say before
we go more music no no you guys you guys
repped I am just so happy to be here Tim
what a great year I know a song that you
guys know I just one I thought of one
too sir do you want to say
a
yeah oh yeah you know this I got get the
I Got lyrics I do but what's the name of
it again my
hero it's a food fighter song and here
it comes there goes my hero that's it
yeah I just don't remember the verses
but go ahead maybe you can get me
started I'll keep it
going it's the verse D start start it
start it for me I'll sing the chorus
[Music]
got yeah to alarm now to talk
about take your pictures down Shake It
Out
truth or
consequence say it
aloud use that
evidence race it
around there goes my
hero watch him as he
goes there goes my hero
here we go don't the best of them bad it
[Applause]
out while the rest of them pet her
out truth of
consequence say it all loud
use that
evidence race it
around there goes my
hero watch him as he
[Music]
goes there goes my hero
Heary
[Music]
I don't know the rest I don't know you
know it's us my hero my voice is i
that's high for me leave it all the
best you know my
hero the one that's
own There Goes My
Hero watch him as he
goes
There Goes My Hero he's
every you know you know uh you know that
sound is that's a drop d tuning that's a
drop d tuning how about how about Stone
Temple Pilots plush you know that one
yes I know it well that's a great one I
can play it can you play that one
yeah this a good song oh that
[Music]
one which one is that this ever long
ever
long I learned that song when I was like
14 give plush no no I think I think I'm
no we got to go actually okay plush is
really good really really good it's uh
I was like you know what song I was like
I was just playing guitar and I picked
up the guitar I was like you know I
remember how to play My Hero from back
when I was like 13 or 14 years old so
I'll just start playing it the thing is
I feel like this is going to be a lot of
Friday nights in 2024 I
feel give it to from the
top where you going all all right we're
rapping it we're rapping it almost save
it for 2024 no we got we got people
waiting for us outside actually I'm
going to get yelled at all right
everybody thanks for hanging out and we
will see you in 2024 see you in